POLICE RADIO: TWO MALE
(BLEEP) ON MOTORBIKES WITH
WALKIE-TALKIES IN THE VICINITY
OF 5900 BLOCK SOUTH AVALON.
IN THE WATTS AREA, FIFTY-TWO
CHEVROLET WHITE, IN COLOR.
CONTAINING FOUR MALE (BLEEP)
WITH A SAWED-OFF SHOTGUN.
RESERVE THE LOOTED STORE AREA.
FOUR MALE (BLEEP) IN A
'52 CHEVY WHITE COLOR
WITH SAWED-OFF SHOTGUNS.
WATTS AREA.
DISPATCHER:
ALL HOLLENBECK UNITS,
BE ON THE ALERT
FOR MOLOTOV COCKTAILS.
ALL HOLLENBECK UNITS,
BE ON THE ALERT FOR
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS.
[SCREAMING]
[INAUDIBLE POLICE RADIO]
[SIRENS]
♪ ♪
REPORTER:
THIS IS WHERE IT BEGAN.
THIS IS WHERE THE
FUSE WAS LIGHTED.
IT BEGAN WITH THE ARREST
BY WHITE OFFICERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OF TWO YOUNG NEGROES.
ONE, ON A CHARGE OF
DRUNK DRIVING; THE OTHER,
HIS BROTHER; HIS PASSENGER.
THEIR MOTHER, WHO LIVES
NEARBY, CAME TO THE SCENE.
THERE WAS AN ARGUMENT;
THERE WAS A SCUFFLE.
BY THEN THE CROWD OF SEVERAL
HUNDRED NEGROES HAD GATHERED,
AND THE STORY OF POLICE
BRUTALITY QUICKLY SPREAD
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY.
REPORTER: UP THE STREET, A
BLOCK OR SO IN THAT DIRECTION,
A CHURCH, WHERE NEGRO
LEADERS PLEADED FOR PEACE
AND WERE REJECTED.
DOWN THAT WAY, THE BUSY
INTERSECTION WHERE CARS WERE
OVERTURNED AND BURNED; WHERE
A TELEVISION TECHNICIAN WAS
PULLED FROM HIS WAGON, AND
ALMOST BEATEN TO DEATH.
REPORTER: IT WAS
THE MOST WIDESPREAD,
MOST DESTRUCTIVE RACIAL
VIOLENCE IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE BURNING AND LOOTING, THE
SHOOTING AND BEATING WENT ON
FOR NEARLY A WEEK.
34 PERSONS WERE KILLED,
ALL BUT 5 OF THEM NEGROES.
REPORTER: POLICE CHIEF
PARKER DESCRIBED LOS ANGELES
NEGRO RIOTERS AS
"MONKEYS IN A ZOO."
AND NEGRO LEADERS
HAVE MORE THAN ONCE CALLED
FOR HIS REMOVAL.
REPORTER: IN CREATING
THE SITUATION,
WHERE WAS THE FAILURE?
IN THE PART OF THE CITY,
THE COUNTY, THE SCHOOLS?
CHIEF PARKER: THIS, I THINK,
IS ONE OF THE DIFFICULTIES IN
MEETING THIS IS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND A FAILURE OTHER
THAN THE PEOPLE THEMSELVES.
NOW THIS IS A VERY
DANGEROUS MOVE BECAUSE IT,
IT SERVES TO SORT OF
SANCTIFY THEIR ACTS.
JOHN SHABAZ: EVERY
GRIEVANCE THAT WAS HAD BY
THE PEOPLE WHO
STARTED THIS THING,
THERE HAS BEEN NOTHING
DONE TO SOLVE IT.
THE ONLY THING THAT WAS
DONE WAS THAT MASSIVE FORCES
WERE BROUGHT IN TO SUPPRESS
THE ACTUAL OVERT ACTION.
REPORTER: HOW HAS
IT AFFECTED YOU?
MAN: JUST GETTING TIRED OF
BEING PUSHED AROUND BY YOU
WHITE PEOPLE, THAT'S ALL.
REPORTER: HOW PUSHED AROUND?
HOW BADLY?
IN WHAT WAY?
MAN: JUST STOPPING US ON THE
STREET, KICKING IN THE DOORS,
TAKEN DOWN TO THE
POLICE STATION,
THEY KICKING YOUR TEETH IN.
REPORTER: WELL THEY'RE
STOPPING PEOPLE ON THE STREET
NOW, BUT I MEAN, THEY
WEREN'T STOPPING PEOPLE IN
THE STREET WHEN THIS STARTED.
MAN: OH YEAH, BUT I'M
NOT THINKING ABOUT NOW.
OH, THEY'VE BEEN DOING IT
A LONG TIME BEFORE NOW.
TOM NEWSOME: DURING
THIS ENTIRE INCIDENT,
WE'VE HEARD CONSTANT
REFERENCES TO RESPECT FOR
LAW AND ORDER, AND
MORE PARTICULARLY,
WHAT THEY MEAN IS RESPECT
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NOW TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
THE PROBLEMS OF THESE PEOPLE,
YOU'D HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
MEANT TO THEM
FOR A HUNDRED YEARS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE WHITE
MAN'S LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR MANY OF
THEIR PARENTS BEING CHASED
OUT OF THE SOUTH
ON ONE PRETEXT OR ANOTHER.
UNDER THOSE CONDITIONS YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT THE PEOPLE
AREN'T GOING TO BE REVERENT
ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THE MEN WHO ENFORCE THE LAW.
REPORTER: WHAT WOULD
MAKE IT BETTER?
WHAT WOULD MAKE ALL
THE RIOTING STOP?
MAN: I DON'T THINK
IT'D EVER STOP, REALLY.
REPORTER: NEVER?
MAN: I MEAN, IT MAY
NOT BE LIKE THIS,
BUT IT'LL NEVER STOP.
I DON'T THINK.
BILL STOUT: THE MCCONE
COMMISSION SOUGHT TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT WATTS.
CAN IT HAPPEN AGAIN?
SO SERIOUS AND EXPLOSIVE
IS THE SITUATION,
SAYS THE COMMISSION, THAT
UNLESS IT IS CHECKED,
THE AUGUST RIOTS MAY
BE ONLY A CURTAIN RAISER TO
WHAT COULD BLOW UP
ONE DAY IN THE FUTURE.
WHAT SHALL IT
AVAIL OUR NATION,
IF WE CAN PLACE A
MAN ON THE MOON,
BUT CANNOT CURE THE
SICKNESS IN OUR CITIES?
THIS IS BILL STOUT
FOR CBS REPORTS,
IN LOS ANGELES, GOOD NIGHT.
♪ [THEME MUSIC PLAYS] ♪
MARTIN LUTHER KING JR: OUT OF
THE ASHES OF THIS COMMUNITY I
THINK THAT IS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BUILD A BETTER SOCIETY IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC SECURITY,
BETTER HOUSING CONDITIONS,
BETTER SCHOOLS, AND TO DEAL
WITH THE POLICE PROBLEM TO
MAKE LOS ANGELES A MODEL
CITY FOR THE NATION.
REPORTER: THOMAS BRADLEY
WAS SWORN IN TODAY AS MAYOR
OF LOS ANGELES, THE LARGEST
CITY IN THIS COUNTRY
EVER TO HAVE A BLACK MAYOR.
BRADLEY IS A FORMER
POLICEMAN AND THE SON OF
A TEXAS SHARECROPPER.
[APPLAUSE].
TOM BRADLEY: TONIGHT
IS NOT JUST A VICTORY FOR
TOM BRADLEY, BUT A
VICTORY FOR PROGRESS,
A VICTORY FOR OUR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[APPLAUSE].
REPORTER: DARYL GATES
HAD SPENT 28 YEARS WORKING
HIS WAY THROUGH THE
RANKS TO THE TOP JOB.
REPORTER 2: HE HAD BEEN CHIEF
PARKER'S DRIVER AND BODYGUARD,
HIS HEIR APPARENT.
DARYL GATES: I'M GONNA PUT
MY STAMP ON THIS ORGANIZATION.
THIS WILL BE A DARYL
GATES DEPARTMENT.
[INAUDIBLE RIOT BANTER].
REPORTER: BLACKS AND
LIBERALS HAVE BECOME INTENSELY
CRITICAL OF WHAT THEY CHARGE
IS EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE
BY THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
WOMAN: DARYL GATES IS
CAUSING THE KIND OF POLARIZATION
THAT IS DANGEROUS.
REPORTER: MANY AMERICANS THINK
OF HOLLYWOOD WHEN THEY THINK
OF LOS ANGELES BUT LOS ANGELES
IS ALSO THE PORT OF ENTRY FOR
AMERICA'S NEW
IMMIGRANTS FROM ASIA AND
FROM LATIN AMERICA.
MAN: OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
CROWD: OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
REPORTER: IN THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS,
MORE THAN TWO MILLION
IMMIGRANTS FROM AROUND THE
WORLD HAVE POURED
INTO THE CITY.
MANY OF THE CITY'S NEW SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE THE AMERICAN
DREAM OF THE FOREIGN BORN.
TOM BRADLEY: OUR CITY
IS A STUNNING ETHNIC
AND CULTURAL MOSAIC.
WE HAVE FORGED A SENSE
OF IDENTITY OF COMMON
CONCERN AND DESTINY.
IN THE LATE DR. MARTIN
LUTHER KING'S WORDS,
"I'M HONORED TO STAND HERE
TODAY AND LOOK OUT UPON FACES
OF MANY DIFFERENT
COLORS INTERMINGLE LIKE THE
WATERS OF A RIVER.
YET I SEE ONLY ONE FACE,
THE FACE OF THE FUTURE."
THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE].
[EXPLOSIONS, GUNFIRE].
PRESIDENT BUSH:
ONE, TWO, THREE.
I AM PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE
THAT AT MIDNIGHT TONIGHT ALL
UNITED STATES AND COALITION
FORCES WILL SUSPEND
OFFENSIVE COMBAT OPERATIONS.
THIS IS A NOT A
TIME OF EUPHORIA,
CERTAINLY NOT A TIME TO GLOAT.
BUT IT IS A TIME OF PRIDE,
PRIDE IN OUR TROOPS,
PRIDE IN OUR NATION AND THE
PEOPLE WHOSE STRENGTH AND
RESOLVE MADE VICTORY
QUICK, DECISIVE, AND JUST.
REPORTER: UH, THIS LATEST
GALLUP POLL SHOWS PEOPLE IN
THE UNITED STATES FEELING
POSITIVE ABOUT THEIR COUNTRY
AND THEIR PRESIDENT
FOLLOWING THE ALLIED VICTORY
IN THE GULF.
66% OF THOSE QUESTIONED
SAY THEY ARE SATISFIED.
REPORTER: BEGINNING
NEXT FRIDAY, L.A. RESIDENTS
WILL HAVE TO DRINK, SHOWER,
AND CONSUME 10% LESS WATER.
MAYOR BRADLEY SIGNED THE WATER
CONSERVATION MEASURE TODAY.
KFI NEWS TIME IS 7:06.
REPORTER: THE ECONOMY
LOOKS NONE TOO GOOD.
IN FACT, UH, THEY KEEP
SAYING THAT THE RECESSION IS
THE ONLY THING PULLING US
OUT OF INFLATION RIGHT NOW.
REPORTER: 57 DEGREES.
FULLERTON, CLOUDY AND 61.
LONG BEACH, PARTLY
CLOUDY AND 60.
AND LANCASTER, PARTLY CLOUDY,
65 DEGREES HERE AT KFI AM 640.
POLICE RADIO: WE ARE
SOUTHBOUND ON PAXTON,
ABOUT 50 MILES PER HOUR.
THERE'S, UH, APPEARS,
APPEARS TO BE THREE MALE BLACKS
IN A VEHICLE.
IT'S A WHITE, UH,
HYUNDAI, I BELIEVE.
POLICE 2: [INAUDIBLE]
WE'RE SOUTHBOUND ON FOOTHILL
FROM VAN NUYS.
THE VEHICLE STOPPED AT
THE LIGHT BUT FAILED TO YIELD
TO THE, UH, POLICE UNIT.
POLICE 3: 23.
WE'RE, UH, FOLLOWING THE UNIT.
WE'RE AT
[INAUDIBLE] NORTHBOUND.
[INAUDIBLE] EASTBOUND.
[HELICOPTER].
[HELICOPTER]
DAN RATHER: AN UNUSUAL
TWIST IN A CASE OF ALLEGED
RACE-BASED POLICE
BRUTALITY IN LOS ANGELES.
NEITHER THE POLICE NOR THE
SUSPECT KNEW THAT A HOME VIDEO
CAMERA HAD CAPTURED THE SCENE.
REPORTER: IT BEGAN AS A
HIGH-SPEED CHASE AND ENDED
EARLY SUNDAY MORNING
WITH THE MOTORIST,
A BLACK MALE BEING
BRUTALLY BEATEN AND KICKED.
REPORTER: THE VICTIM WAS
STRUCK AS MANY AS 56 TIMES,
AND SUFFERED SEVERAL
BROKEN BONES.
LAWYER: 56 TIMES.
THAT'S WHAT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC SAW ON VIDEOTAPE.
REPORTER: GEORGE HOLLIDAY
LIVES ACROSS THE STREET.
HE HAD HIS VIDEO CAMERA OUT
AND RECORDED WHAT HAPPENED AS
THE SUSPECT WAS
BEING ARRESTED.
GEORGE HOLLIDAY: GOT MY
CAMERA SORT OF READY AND LOOKED
ACROSS THE STREET AND
THAT'S WHEN I SAW THAT THE
ACTION WAS GOING ON.
CNN REPORTER: THE
SUSPECT IDENTIFIED AS
RODNEY GLEN KING.
REPORTER: KING, WHO IS MARRIED
AND HAS TWO STEP CHILDREN,
WAS ON PAROLE AFTER SERVING
TIME FOR ARMED ROBBERY.
HIS WIFE SAYS THAT'S NO
EXCUSE FOR WHAT HAPPENED.
CRYSTAL KING: IT WAS
A TRAFFIC VIOLATION.
HOW COME THEY JUST COULDN'T
ARREST HIM AND GIVE HIM SOME
KIND OF FINE OR SOMETHING?
WHY DID THEY HAVE TO BEAT
THE MESS OUT OF HIM LIKE THAT?
REPORTER: DOCTORS SAID THAT
HE SUFFERED A CONCUSSION.
ONE OF HIS EYE SOCKETS
WAS PULVERIZED.
HIS CHEEKBONE WAS SO PUSHED
IN FROM THE BLOWS TO HIS FACE
THAT IT WOULD REQUIRE
RECONSTRUCTIVE SURGERY.
STEVEN LERMAN: FROM
WHAT I'VE SEEN,
NONE OF THE PRISONERS
OF WAR FROM AMERICAN FORCES
TAKEN BY SADDAM HUSSEIN
CAME BACK BEATEN THAT BADLY.
REPORTER: LOS ANGELES
POLICE SAY THE INCIDENT WAS
NOT RACIALLY MOTIVATED,
BUT THE BLACK COMMUNITY IS
NOT BUYING THAT.
ABOUT 300 MEMBERS
OF THE NAACP MARCHED ON
POLICE HEADQUARTERS TODAY.
[PROTESTORS
CHANTING INAUDIBLY].
DARYL GATES: THIS
IS AN ABERRATION.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD NEVER HAVE HAPPENED.
WE HAD IN PLACE ALL OF THE
PROCEDURES THAT WOULD KEEP IT
FROM HAPPENING.
THOSE PROCEDURES FELL DOWN
BECAUSE OF HUMAN ERROR.
REPORTER: THE ACLU SAID IT
RECEIVES ABOUT 55 CALLS A WEEK
FROM PEOPLE ALLEGING
POLICE BRUTALITY.
RAMONA RIPSTON: THE INCIDENT
EARLY SUNDAY MORNING IS
NOT AN ISOLATED INCIDENT.
THE DIFFERENCE THIS TIME
IS THAT WE HAVE THE PROOF.
STEVEN LERMAN: WHAT
HAPPENED TO THE AUDIO?
REPORTER: DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEA AT ALL HOW MANY TIMES
YOU WERE HIT BY A CLUB?
WHAT DO YOU REMEMBER ABOUT
THAT AFTER [INAUDIBLE]?
RODNEY KING: SEVERAL
TIMES, SEVERAL TIMES.
AND THEN STOMPED AND KICKED.
STEVEN LERMAN: PICK UP YOUR.
REPORTER: LIFT YOUR SHIRT.
STEVEN LERMAN:
THIS IS SOMETHING.
RODNEY KING: LIKE THIS?
STEVEN LERMAN:
SEE THIS, SEE THAT?
REPORTER: [INAUDIBLE]
WHAT IS THAT FROM?
RODNEY KING: THAT'S FROM,
UM, SOME KIND OF DEVICE
THAT THEY USED.
THEY, UM, SH, SHOCKED ME.
THEY GOT A BIG
KICK OUT OF THAT.
REPORTER: WHAT MAKES YOU SAY
THEY GOT A KICK OUT OF IT?
RODNEY KING: BECAUSE OF HOW
LONG THEY LEFT IT IN ME.
YOU KNOW?
IT WAS LIKE THEY HAD A
LITTLE TOY AND THEY WANTED TO
SEE HOW IT WORKED.
REPORTER: WHAT KINDS
OF THINGS DID YOU HEAR
FROM THE OFFICERS?
DID YOU HEAR ANY
KIND OF SLURS AT ALL?
RODNEY KING: WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
WHAT SLURS?
REPORTER: WERE THERE
ANY KIND OF RACIAL COMMENTS
MADE AT ALL?
RODNEY KING: OH, RACIAL?
NO, I DIDN'T, NO,
I DIDN'T HEAR ANY.
MAN: WELL YOU CAN CUT THIS
FROM THE TAPE IF, IF YOU WANT,
BUT ROD'S FAMILY HAS,
UH, MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING
TO TURN THIS INTO A, UH,
RACIAL CRUSADE.
STEVEN LERMAN: MR. KING
DOESN'T WANT TO MAKE, UH,
MAKE IT OUT AS THOUGH THEY
DID THIS JUST BECAUSE HE
WAS A BLACK MAN.
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN INCIDENTAL
TO IT AND THERE MAY BE
PERSONAL MOTIVES THAT
THESE OFFICERS HAD THAT
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT YET.
BUT AT THE PRESENT TIME,
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THAT.
MAN: WHAT WE GOT, LARRY?
♪ ♪
IRA REINER: AS YOU KNOW,
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
HAS BEEN CONDUCTING AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE BEATING
OF RODNEY KING.
AND I'M ANNOUNCING TODAY THAT
WE HAVE OBTAINED INDICTMENTS
AGAINST FOUR LOS ANGELES
POLICE OFFICERS FOR THEIR ROLE
IN THE BEATING OF MR. KING.
LAPD OFFICER LAURENCE
POWELL, TIMOTHY WIND,
THEODORE BRISENO AND SERGEANT
STACEY KOON HAVE BEEN INDICTED
FOR ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY
WEAPON AND FOR EXCESSIVE USE
OF FORCE UNDER
COLOR OF AUTHORITY.
OFFICER POWELL AND WIND AND
SERGEANT KOON ARE FURTHER
CHARGED WITH INFLICTING
GREAT BODILY INJURY IN THE
BRUTAL ATTACK THAT HAS
NOW BEEN WITNESSED BY
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW THESE
ARE FELONIES PUNISHABLE BY
UP TO SEVEN YEARS
IN STATE PRISON.
SERGEANT KOON AND OFFICER
POWELL HAVE ALSO BEEN INDICTED
FOR FILING FALSE REPORTS.
ALL FOUR OFFICERS
SURRENDERED THIS MORNING TO
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THEY HAVE BEEN ARRESTED,
FINGER PRINTED,
AND PHOTOGRAPHED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
REPORTER: ANY BAIL
RECOMMENDATION AT THE
PROCEEDING THIS MORNING
FOR THE OFFICERS?
[INAUDIBLE COURTROOM CHATTER].
[NEWSCAST OPENING MUSIC].
ANNOUNCER: THIS IS WORLD NEWS
TONIGHT WITH PETER JENNINGS.
SITTING IN TONIGHT IN
WASHINGTON, TED KOPPEL.
TED KOPPEL: GOOD EVENING.
THE EVIDENCE IS
NEW, IT'S DRAMATIC,
AND IT'S DEVASTATING TO THOSE
LOS ANGELES POLICE OFFICERS
INVOLVED IN THE
MARCH 3RD BEATING OF
THAT BLACK MOTORIST.
REPORTER: ONE OF THE TWO
OFFICERS WHO WIELDED BATONS
THAT EVENING RELAYED A
MESSAGE AFTER THE ARREST TO
ANOTHER CAR SAYING, QUOTE:
"SOUNDS ALMOST AS
EXCITING AS OUR LAST CALL.
IT WAS RIGHT OUT OF
GORILLAS IN THE MIST."
ONE POLICEMAN INVOLVED
IN THE BEATING SAID QUOTE,
"I HAVEN'T BEATEN ANYONE
THIS BAD IN A LONG TIME."
ANOTHER JOKED LATER SAYING,
"I'M SURE THE LIZARD
DIDN'T DESERVE IT."
MAYOR TOM BRADLEY SAID
THE TRANSCRIPT RAISES MORE
QUESTIONS ABOUT
POLICE COMMAND.
TOM BRADLEY: I THINK IT HAS
BEEN DEVASTATING TO THE IMAGE
OF THE CITY AND ESPECIALLY
TO OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT.
JOHN MACK: IT'S VERY
APPARENT THAT SOME, NOT ALL,
BUT SOME OF THOSE OFFICERS
ARE CLEARLY OUT OF CONTROL AND
THEY HAVE TO ULTIMATELY BE
WILLING TO TAKE A GOOD HARD
LOOK AT THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE DEPARTMENT.
CROWD: GATES GOT TO GO, NOW.
GATES GOT TO GO NOW.
GATES GOT TO GO, NOW.
ZEV YARLOSLAVSKY:
MR. PRESIDENT,
ALL OF US I THINK
HAVE BEEN, UH,
STUNNED BY WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
AND, UH, I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
THE CHIEF OR ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE CITY WOULD CONDONE
THE KIND OF, UH,
CONVERSATION THAT TOOK PLACE
BOTH ELECTRONICALLY AND BY
VOICE, UH, IN THAT FOOTHILL
DIVISION THAT NIGHT.
BLACKS ARE NOT ANIMALS.
THEY'RE NOT LIZARDS.
THEY'RE NOT APES.
THEY'RE NOT GORILLAS ANY
MORE THAN ANY OF US ARE.
THEY'RE HUMAN BEINGS.
THE FIRST WAY TO OPEN THE DOOR
TO BRUTALIZING PEOPLE IN ANY,
ANY PLACE IS TO CHEAPEN
THEIR WORTH AS HUMAN BEINGS.
AND WHEN I READ THE
TRANSCRIPTS OF THE
CONVERSATION I WAS APPALLED.
BUT THE ABILITY TO FREELY
CONVERSE IN RACIST TERMINOLOGY
SUGGESTS A LEVEL OF TOLERANCE
FOR THAT KIND OF DISCUSSION
THAT, UH, THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE
BY ANY STANDARD OF DECENCY.
DARYL GATES: WELL
FIRST OF ALL IS, UH,
THIS IS A DEPARTMENT THAT
THIS COUNCIL HAS SUPPORTED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THIS IS A POLICE DEPARTMENT
THAT HAS SUPPORTED YOU,
EACH OF YOU.
I JUST TELL YOU THIS.
IF YOU DON'T SPEAK OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT THAT HAVE SERVED
THE PEOPLE OF THIS CITY WELL,
IF YOU DON'T DO THAT AT THIS
CRUCIAL MOMENT IN OUR HISTORY,
THEN I'M GONNA TELL YOU,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A POLICE
DEPARTMENT THAT IS NOT GOING
TO BE THE KIND OF
DEPARTMENT THAT YOU WANT,
THE KIND OF DEPARTMENT
THE PEOPLE DESERVE.
MAN: MR. WOO.
MR. WOO: THANK YOU.
UH, I WANT TO KNOW DID
YOU MEAN THAT AS A THREAT?
IN OTHER WORDS THAT IF, IF,
IF I OR OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COUNCIL ARE GOING TO BE
CRITICIZING YOU OR THE
DEPARTMENT, ARE YOU
SAYING THAT YOU WILL,
WILL WITHHOLD SUPPORT OF
THESE SERVICES TO FIGHT CRIME
IN OUR DISTRICTS?
DARYL GATES: THAT IS THE MOST
INSULTING THING I HAVE HEARD
ON THIS COUNCIL FLOOR IN ALL
THE TIME I'VE BEEN HERE AND
I'VE BEEN HERE A LOT LONGER
THAN YOU'VE BEEN ALIVE.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
THIS IS A PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE ARE?
[INAUDIBLE COURTROOM CHATTER].
MAN: HE SHOVED ME
UP AGAINST THE WALL AND
STARTED TO STRANGLE ME.
I COULD NOT BREATHE.
THEY TRIED TO KICK
ME IN THE TESTICLES.
HE THREW ME ASIDE AND SAID,
"GET THE (BLEEP)
OUT OF HERE NOW."
THAT IS THE LAPD.
[APPLAUSE].
MAN 2: WE FOUND ONE CASE
WHERE A DOG ATTACKED AND
BIT THE CHEST OF
A 16-YEAR-OLD GIRL.
THE DOGS ARE QUITE
LARGE AND AGGRESSIVE.
THEY WILL RIP AWAY
FLESH AND MUSCLE.
THEY WILL TEAR OUT BLOOD
VESSELS AND THEY WILL
SOMETIMES BREAK BONES.
MAN: THE POLICE SEND
OUR KIDS COMPLETELY
CONFLICTING MESSAGES.
THEY'RE IN OUR SCHOOLS
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND YET OUR KIDS SEE THEM ON
TV BEATING A MAN LIKE A DOG.
MAN 2: THE POLICE ARE
TRAINED TO APPROACH BLACK MEN
AS CRIMINALS FIRST
AND CITIZENS SECOND.
MAN 3: BUT BEFORE YOU
LEAVE SOUTH CENTRAL,
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND THAT
VERBAL ABUSE HAPPENS HERE
EVERY DAY AND EVERY NIGHT:
"GET OUT OF THE CAR, NIGGER.
ASSUME THE POSITION, NIGGER.
SIT ON THE CURB, NIGGER.
LIE FACE DOWN ON
THE GROUND, NIGGER."
WE'RE SAYING THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE CONFRONTED WITH.
AND WHEN WE SPEAK OUT,
THE FIRST THING THEY SAY IS,
"WHY ARE THEY
GETTING SO RESTLESS?
WHY SHOULD NOT
WE GET RESTLESS?
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
TAKING THIS TO THE STREETS AND
WE AIN'T TALKING
ABOUT JUST MARCHING.
[APPLAUSE].
CONNIE CHUNG: ANOTHER WIDELY
PUBLICIZED INCIDENT CAPTURED
ON VIDEOTAPE IN LOS ANGELES.
REPORTER: THIS GRAINY,
SECURITY CAMERA VIDEOTAPE
GRAPHICALLY DEPICTS
THE LAST FEW MOMENTS OF
15-YEAR-OLD
LATASHA HARLINS' LIFE.
STOREOWNER SOON JA DU THOUGHT
15-YEAR-OLD LATASHA HARLINS
WAS GOING TO STEAL
SOME ORANGE JUICE.
MICHAEL BOSTIC: SHE HAD
THE MONEY IN HER HAND.
YOU COULD SEE THE
MONEY IN THE VIDEOTAPE.
AND UH, THE SUSPECT GRABBED
THE BACKPACK AND THERE BECAME
A, A PHYSICAL ALTERCATION
OVER THE BACKPACK.
AND UH, AS OUR VICTIM UH,
TURNED TO WALK AWAY FROM THE
SCENE, THE SUSPECT AH, RAISED
A WEAPON AND SHOT THE VICTIM
IN THE BACK OF THE HEAD.
WOMAN: LATASHA WAS A 'A'
STUDENT, HONOR ROLL STUDENT.
SHE GOT MONEY EVERY WEEK FOR
HER ALLOWANCE SO SHE DID NOT
HAVE TO STEAL ORANGE JUICE.
REPORTER: THE STORE CLERK,
A KOREAN WOMAN,
IS NOW IN JAIL.
THE BLACK COMMUNITY IS
OUTRAGED OVER THE KILLING.
THE NAACP IS DEMANDING THE
CLERK BE TRIED FOR MURDER.
CROWD: WE WANT JUSTICE.
STOP KILLING OUR CHILDREN.
WE WANT JUSTICE!
REPORTER: THE CASE HAS BECOME
A SYMBOL OF TENSIONS BETWEEN
TWO LARGE GROUPS IN THIS
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE CITY,
AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND THE KOREANS,
WHO'VE BECOME SUCCESSFUL
MERCHANTS IN MANY OF THE
POOREST BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS.
AS MANY AS 300,000 KOREANS
LIVE IN LOS ANGELES,
MANY OF THEM IN AN AREA
KNOWN AS KOREATOWN.
SOME BLACKS SEE THE KOREANS
AS A MERCHANT CLASS THAT TAKES
ADVANTAGE OF THE
BLACK COMMUNITY.
WOMAN: WHY DON'T YOU OPEN
A MARKET THAT WE CAN USE
FOR OUR FAMILY?
MAN: GO BACK TO KOREA.
EDWARD CHANG: WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED THAT THIS INCIDENT
MAY BE DETRIMENTAL TO
THE POSITIVE EFFORTS BETWEEN
THE TWO COMMUNITIES.
IN ORDER TO
STRENGTHEN OUR BONDS,
WE WILL ACTIVELY JOIN WITH
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
TO DEVELOP MEASURES TO
PREVENT FURTHER TRAGEDY.
JUDGE KARLIN: MISS SHEPHERD,
WOULD YOU PLEASE GIVE THE
BAILIFF THE UM, VERDICT FORM?
THANK YOU.
WOULD THE COURT PLEASE
READ THE VERDICTS?
BAILIFF: TITLE OF
COURT AND CAUSE.
WE THE JURY, IN THE ABOVE
ENTITLED ACTION FIND THE
DEFENDANT SOON JA DU GUILTY
OF VOLUNTARY MANSLAUGHTER IN
VIOLATION OF PENAL CODE
SECTION 192A, A FELONY.
A LESSOR INCLUDED OFFENSE
TO THAT CHARGE IN [INAUDIBLE]
OF THE INDICTMENT.
WE FURTHER FIND THE ALLEGATION
THAT IN THE COMMISSION.
JUDGE KARLIN: IT IS
NOW A TIME FOR HEALING.
IT IS NOT A TIME FOR RHETORIC,
WHICH SERVES NO PURPOSE
OTHER THAN TO FUEL THE FIRE.
IT'S LIKE THROWING
GASOLINE ON A FIRE
THAT'S ALREADY BURNING.
IT IS MY OPINION THAT
MRS. DU IS NOT A DANGER TO
THE COMMUNITY AND THAT
SHE IS NOT GOING TO REOFFEND.
I KNOW A CRIMINAL
WHEN I SEE ONE.
I KNOW A PERSON WHO PRESENTS
A DANGER TO THE COMMUNITY
WHEN I SEE ONE.
WHEN I DON'T, I TREAT
THAT PERSON AS SOMETHING
OTHER THAN THAT.
WOMAN: SHE GOT
AWAY WITH MURDER.
MAN: GODDAMN, SURE HOPE SO
THAT THERE WILL BE ALL THE
HELL IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
WOMAN: I HOPE
SOMEBODY WOULD CARE.
MAN: AND WOULD
STAND UP AND SEE THIS INSANITY
FOR EXACTLY WHAT IT IS.
WOMAN: ABOUT THE DEATH OF A
CHILD, YOU CAN MURDER A CHILD.
MAN: BLACK PEOPLE, ONCE AGAIN,
BEING UNJUSTLY TREATED BY THE.
WOMAN: AND WALK AWAY,
AND STAY ON THE STREET.
MAN: GET THE CAMERAS OFF.
GET THE CAMERA OUT OF MY FACE.
WOMAN: SINCE WE DON'T
PICK COTTON ANYMORE,
AND CUT SUGARCANE, WE ARE,
WE'RE, OUR LIVES IS NOT,
NOT WORTH ANYTHING?
RICHARD.
MAN: GET OUT OF MY FACE.
WOMAN: RICHARD, RICHARD.
MAN: I MEAN YOU CAN HAVE
A BLACK PERSON KILLED, UH,
WITH A VIDEO WITH EYEWITNESSES
AND THIS IS WHAT YOU'LL GET.
WOMAN 2: RICHARD,
RICHARD, STOP THAT.
RICHARD.
MAN: GET OUT OF MY FACE.
WOMAN 2: RICHARD.
WOMAN: GET HIM
ON THE ELEVATOR.
SHUT THE DOOR.
MAXINE WATERS: UNFORTUNATELY,
A JUDGE WHO'S PROBABLY NEVER
BEEN DOWN HERE, A JUDGE WHO
PROBABLY KNOWS VERY LITTLE
ABOUT THIS COMMUNITY.
A JUDGE DECIDED THAT THE
LIFE WAS NOT VALUABLE ENOUGH.
MAN: LATASHA WAS KILLED,
OUR FAMILY WAS KILLED.
RACISM IS NOT THE
KOREAN KILLING HER,
RACISM IS THE COURT SYSTEM
THAT ALLOWS HER TO KILL HER.
DANNY BAKEWELL: WE
HAVE TO SHOW LOS ANGELES
THAT WE ARE RESILIENT.
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO THE
SALVATION OF OUR PEOPLE.
AND WE ARE PREPARED TO
BE CIVILLY DISOBEDIENT.
[INAUDIBLE CHANTING]
[INAUDIBLE]
♪ ♪
[HELICOPTER].
REPORTER: JUDGE BERNARD KAMINS
CAUGHT OBSERVERS BY SURPRISE
WHEN HE REVERSED HIMSELF AND
ANNOUNCED THAT HE WOULD GRANT
A CHANGE A VENUE IN THE TRIAL
OF THE FOUR POLICE OFFICERS
CHARGED IN CONNECTION
WITH THE BEATING OF
MOTORIST RODNEY KING.
JUDGE KAMINS: THE CHANGE
OF VENUE MOTION IS GREATLY
ENTWINED WITH WHETHER
WE CAN GET JURORS,
AND I'M VERY CONCERNED
WHETHER WE CAN GET JURORS
WHO ARE UNTAINTED.
REPORTER: OTHER
HIGH-PROFILE CASES,
SUCH AS THOSE OF CHARLES
MANSON AND ROBERT KENNEDY
ASSASSIN SIRHAN SIRHAN
WERE NOT TRANSFERRED OUT
OF LOS ANGELES DESPITE
HIGH PUBLICITY.
BUT DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
SAY THIS CASE IS DIFFERENT.
JOHN BARNETT: EVERYONE
HAS OPINION ON THE UH,
GUILT OR INNOCENCE
OF THESE DEFENDANTS,
AND THAT'S WHY IT WOULD
BE VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
A FAIR TRIAL HERE.
REPORTER: TO MOVE
THE TRIAL AWAY FROM THE
SWARMING CONTROVERSY
IN THE L.A. MEDIA,
THE VENUE WAS
CHANGED TO THE SIMI VALLEY,
A MOSTLY WHITE SUBURB
OF LOS ANGELES WHERE MANY
POLICE OFFICERS LIVE.
SIMI VALLEY IS A
TOWN OF 100,000 PEOPLE
JUST 35 MILES NORTH
OF LOS ANGELES.
SIMI VALLEY RESIDENTS
ARE 88% WHITE,
JUST ONE AND A HALF PERCENT
OF THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
HERE ARE BLACK.
REPORTER: THINKING ABOUT RIGHT
NOW BEFORE YOU GO AND START?
DARRYL MOUNGER: START
BANGING UP MY CAR I'M GONNA,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE ANOTHER
THE RODNEY KING INCIDENT.
STACEY KOON: WAITING
A LONG TIME FOR THIS.
REPORTER: FINALLY GETTING
IT GOING, A GOOD FEELING?
STACEY KOON: YES.
ATTORNEY: MORNING.
♪ ♪
DID YOU SAY ANYTHING
TO, UH, MR. KING?
LAURENCE POWELL: YES.
ATTORNEY: WHAT DID
YOU SAY TO HIM?
LAURENCE POWELL: I YELLED AT
HIM TO LAY DOWN ON THE GROUND,
GET DOWN ON THE GROUND,
A SERIES OF THOSE COMMANDS.
ATTORNEY: A SERIES?
LAURENCE POWELL: YES.
ATTORNEY: YOU REPEATED IT?
LAURENCE POWELL: RIGHT.
ATTORNEY: AND, UH, TELL
THE JURY WHAT HAPPENED NEXT.
LAURENCE POWELL: A, I
CONTINUED TO HIT HIM AND THEN
KNOCKED HIM TO THE GROUND,
YELLED AT HIM TO STAY ON THE
GROUND AND HE REPEATED
THE MOTION AGAIN,
GETTING UP AGAIN.
I WAS COMPLETELY IN
FEAR FOR MY LIFE,
SCARED TO DEATH THAT IF THIS
GUY GOT BACK UP HE WAS GONNA
TAKE MY GUN AWAY FROM ME, OR
THERE WAS GONNA BE A SHOOTING,
AND I WAS DOING EVERYTHING
I COULD TO KEEP HIM DOWN
ON THE GROUND.
ATTORNEY: AT ANY TIME DURING
THIS EVENING DID IT GO THROUGH
YOUR MIND THAT THIS
WAS NOT A HUMAN BEING THAT
YOU WERE BEATING?
LAURENCE POWELL: NO.
ATTORNEY: UM, HE WASN'T
AN ANIMAL, WAS HE?
LAURENCE POWELL: NO, SIR,
JUST ACTING LIKE ONE.
ATTORNEY: HE WASN'T, HE
WAS JUST ACTING LIKE ONE?
LAURENCE POWELL: YES, SIR.
ATTORNEY: WAS HE
ACTING LIKE A GORILLA?
LAURENCE POWELL: NO, SIR.
ATTORNEY: NOW THIS CALL
THAT INVOLVED THESE AFRICAN
AMERICANS, WAS IT IN A JUNGLE?
LAURENCE POWELL: IN A WHAT?
ATTORNEY: A JUNGLE.
LAURENCE POWELL: NO.
ATTORNEY: WAS IT AT THE ZOO?
ATTORNEY: WERE THERE
ANY GORILLAS AROUND?
LAURENCE POWELL:
I DIDN'T SEE ANY.
ATTORNEY: SERGEANT, WHAT
ARE YOU WATCHING DURING
ALL OF THIS?
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING WHEN
YOU'RE FOCUSING ON THIS?
STACEY KOON: I'M
THINKING THAT, UH,
MR. KING HAS
BEEN SUBJECTED TO, UH,
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF,
UH, UH, PAIN
AND HE'S, UH, NOT,
IT'S ALMOST AS IF HIS BODY
IS ANESTHETIZED TO THE PAIN.
ATTORNEY: WHAT WERE
YOU THINKING NOW?
STACEY KOON: I WAS THINKING
THAT I HAVE EXHAUSTED ALL OF
UH, THE USE OF FORCE THAT
I HAVE SHORT OF DEADLY FORCE
AT THIS TIME.
I'M THINKING AT THIS
TIME I'M EITHER GONNA HAVE
TO USE A
CHOKEHOLD OR MY WEAPON.
ATTORNEY: AND WHY DIDN'T YOU
WANT TO USE A CHOKEHOLD, SIR?
STACEY KOON: BECAUSE,
UM, IN LOS ANGELES THE
CHOKEHOLD, UH, IS ASSOCIATED
WITH DEATH OF BLACKS.
ATTORNEY: HOW DO YOU VIEW
LOOKING AT THIS VIDEOTAPE, SIR?
STACEY KOON: IT'S
VIOLENT AND IT'S BRUTAL.
ATTORNEY: WAS THIS
ANYTHING THAT YOU ENJOYED?
STACEY KOON: NO.
ATTORNEY: WHY WAS IT DONE?
STACEY KOON: IT'S
DONE TO CONTROL, UH,
AN AGGRESSIVE COMBATIVE
SUSPECT AND SOMETIMES POLICE
WORK IS BRUTAL.
THAT'S JUST A FACT OF LIFE.
REPORTER: EVERY DAY, REGULAR
FOLKS FROM THE PUBLIC FILE IN
TO WATCH THE TRIAL AND YOU CAN
TOO IF YOU CAN BEAT THE RUSH.
WOMAN: ACTUALLY, YOU HAVE
A PRETTY GOOD CHANCE.
UM, WE HAVE 17 SEATS
ALLOCATED FOR THE, UM, PUBLIC.
HOWEVER, THE OTHER SEATS
THAT WE HAVE RESERVED,
IF PEOPLE DON'T SHOW UP
FOR THOSE SEATS THEN WE
IMMEDIATELY OPEN THEM
UP TO THE PUBLIC.
REPORTER: IF YOU WANT
TO COME HERE THOUGH,
HERE'S A LITTLE ADVICE.
WOMAN: THEY SHOULD DRESS
APPROPRIATELY FOR COURT,
OF COURSE.
UM, NOTHING THAT SAYS
ANYTHING ABOUT THE TRIAL ITSELF
OR ANY TYPE OF RACIAL SLURS,
UM, ANYTHING THAT MIGHT BE
MISCONSTRUED BY ANYONE.
SECURITY: WELL ANYWAY,
COURT ORDER COVERS THAT.
DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER
SHIRT IN THE CAR?
MAN: I'LL LOOK AND SEE.
SECURITY:
OTHERWISE [INAUDIBLE].
ATTORNEY: STOPPING
THE VIDEO AT 03:51:02,
HAVE YOU SEEN MR. KING
SWING AT ANYONE?
GEORGE DUKE: NO, I HAVEN'T.
ATTORNEY: UH, HAVE YOU
SEEN HIM PUNCH AT ANYONE?
GEORGE DUKE: NO, I HAVEN'T.
ATTORNEY: IS YOUR TESTIMONY
THEN AT ANY POINT AFTER
03:42:20, ANY BATON BLOW
RECEIVED BY MR. KING IS
UNREASONABLE AND UNNECESSARY?
MICHAEL BOSTIC:
YES SIR, IT IS.
DARRYL MOUNGER: HAD
SERGEANT KOON NOT BEEN THERE
TO CONTROL THAT SITUATION,
AS UGLY AS IT LOOKS,
RODNEY KING WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN HOME NOW.
AND MAYBE SERGEANT KOON
WOULD HAVE HAD TO GO TELL
SOME OFFICER'S FAMILY WHY
THEY DIDN'T COME HOME.
TERRY WHITE: YOU'VE
GOT THIS MAN DOWN.
HE'S NOT DOING ANYTHING.
HE'S NOT TRYING TO ESCAPE.
HE'S NOT TRYING TO RESIST.
WHEN YOU REACH THAT POINT
ON THAT TAPE WHERE YOU SAY,
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH, THAT'S WHEN
UNREASONABLE FORCE STARTS.
JOHN BARNETT: OUR WHOLE SYSTEM
OF JUSTICE IS BASED ON THE
BELIEF THAT IF WE GET TWELVE
PEOPLE FROM THE COMMUNITY TO
FAIRLY AND DISPASSIONATELY
DECIDE THIS ISSUE,
DEVOID OF PREJUDICE AND BIAS,
THEN THE TRUTH WILL COME OUT,
JUSTICE WILL BE DONE.
THINK AHEAD AND MAKE A
DECISION NOW ABOUT WHICH YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO SAY YEARS FROM
NOW, "I WAS TRUE TO MY OATH.
I WAS TRUE TO THE LAW.
I WAS TRUE TO MYSELF."
♪ ♪
REPORTER: WHO'S
THE PACKAGE FOR?
HOW'RE YOU DOING?
IS THAT FOR THE OFFICERS?
MAN: YES, SIR.
MAN 2: THE DEFENDANTS?
DO YOU SUPPORT THOSE GUYS?
MAN: YOU BETTER BELIEVE IT.
MAN 2: WHY?
THOSE GUYS ARE HEATHENS.
MAN: YEAH.
MAN 2: THOSE GUYS ARE
ANIMALISTIC HEATHENS.
MAN: YEAH, THEY'RE,
THEY'RE HOLDING THE
JUNGLE BACK, TIGER.
MAN 2: JUNGLE?
NO.
MAN: YES SIR.
MAN 2: I THINK THE DEFENDANTS
ARE JUNGLE PEOPLE, OKAY?
FOR YOU TO SUPPORT THOSE
DEFENDANTS IS ANOTHER,
IT'S AN INDICATION
OF YOUR HUMANITY.
YOUR IMMORALITY.
MAN: YOU GOT A, YOU GOT A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT OF POOR
JUDGMENT, AND YOU'RE
EXERCISING IT RIGHT NOW.
MAN 2: NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
YOU HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT OF JUST
INCONSPICUOUS INHUMANITIES.
MAN: AH, BLOW IT!
MAN 2: YEAH, RIGHT.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS
FOR YOU TO DO THAT.
MAN: YEAH.
KEEP YOUR MOUTH SHUT.
I DIDN'T ASK YOU A DAMN THING.
MAN 2: I HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, BROTHER.
MAN: YEAH, WELL AIM
IT SOMEWHERE ELSE.
MAN 2: OKAY,
THAT'S DISGUSTING.
MAN: YEAH.
STACEY KOON: GOOD
MORNING, GENTLEMEN.
REPORTERS:
GOOD MORNING SERGEANT.
STACEY KOON: HOW'D YOUR BALL
GAME AND BARBECUE GO YESTERDAY?
REPORTER: OH THE
BARBECUE WAS GREAT.
LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE
DRESSED FOR IT TODAY.
STACEY KOON: I GOT MY
CLOTHES IN THE CAR, SHHH!
REPORTER: CAN YOU JUST
TELL US WHAT IT'S LIKE THE
LAST FEW DAYS FOR YOU?
TED BRISENO: IT'S BEEN HARD
BUT UH, I'LL, I'LL MAKE IT.
I'LL MAKE IT.
REPORTER: THE WAITING'S GOT
TO BE EXTREMELY TOUGH, THOUGH.
TED BRISENO: SURE.
REPORTER: THANK YOU.
JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY, HAVE
YOU MADE A CONSCIOUS DECISION
TO TALK TO US AND
TELL YOUR SIDE OF IT?
LAURENCE POWELL: NO NOT
REALLY, IT'S JUST AH.
REPORTERS: DAVID,
GET DOWN, DAVID.
LAURENCE POWELL: I HAVE
NOTHING TO HIDE, REALLY.
MAN: YOU SHOULD.
LAURENCE POWELL: I BETTER
GET IN TO COURT, I'M LATE.
REPORTER: WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THE DONUTS THERE?
LAURENCE POWELL: I DON'T
KNOW IF THEY'RE DONUTS YET.
I HAVEN'T OPENED IT YET.
MAN: AND YOU'RE
NOT A HERO BUDDY.
YOU'RE A HEATHEN!
YOU'RE AN ANIMALISTIC HEATHEN.
MAN 2: GOOD LUCK.
WE'RE BEHIND YOU!
GO FOR IT, GUY.
REPORTER: EXCUSE ME, MR. WIND?
HOW IS IT WAITING RIGHT NOW?
TIMOTHY WIND: WAITING.
REPORTER: YEAH.
NO, I MEAN FOR THE VERDICT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT IT?
IT'S GOT TO BE REALLY TOUGH.
PAT: LET'S GO TO BRYAN
LIVE NOW AT THE COURTHOUSE
IN SIMI VALLEY.
BRYAN JENKINS: WELL PAT,
EVERYBODY IS IN A STATE OF
NERVOUS, UH, A STATE OF
NERVOUSNESS JUST WAITING FOR
THE DECISION TO COME DOWN.
RIGHT NOW, UH, THERE
ARE PEOPLE OUTSIDE.
UH, THERE WAS, UH,
BEEFED UP SECURITY HERE,
UH FOR WHAT, WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT, UH, I'M
SUPPOSING THAT, UH,
THEY'RE PREPARED FOR
WHATEVER MAY ARISE IN THE
EVENT OF A VERDICT.
SO, UH, EVERYONE'S IN A,
A STATE OF NERVOUS ANTICIPATION.
REPORTER: 5,
4, 3, 2, 1, HELLO.
WOMAN: THEY WANT TO COME
TO US LIVE AS SOON AS WE
CAN GET OUR PICTURE.
BRYAN JENKINS: UH.
I'M TOLD THAT, UH, WE
HAVE THE COURTROOM VERDICT SO
WE WILL GO LIVE THERE.
JUDGE WEISBERG: A VERDICT'S
BEEN REACHED ON ALL COUNTS AS
TO ALL DEFENDANTS WHO ARE
MENTIONED IN THOSE COUNTS AND
HAVE YOU BROUGHT WITH
YOU THE VERDICT FORMS
FOR THOSE COUNTS?
OKAY, WOULD YOU HAND THEM
TO THE BAILIFF PLEASE?
BAILIFF: TITLE OF
COURT AND CAUSE.
WE THE JURY, IN THE
ABOVE ENTITLED ACTION,
FIND THE DEFENDANT
LAURENCE M. POWELL NOT GUILTY
OF THE CRIME OF ASSAULT
BY FORCE LIKELY TO
PRODUCE GREAT BODILY INJURY,
AND WITH A DEADLY WEAPON,
IN VIOLATION OF PENAL CODE
SECTION 245A1, A FELONY,
AS CHARGED IN ACCOUNT ONE
OF THE AMENDED INDICTMENT,
THIS 29TH DAY OF APRIL,
1992, SIGNED BY THE FOREMAN.
WE THE JURY, IN THE
ABOVE ENTITLED ACTION,
FIND THE DEFENDANT
TIMOTHY E. WIND NOT GUILTY
OF THE CRIME OF
ASSAULT BY FORCE LIKELY TO
PRODUCE GREAT BODILY INJURY,
AND WITH A DEADLY WEAPON.
WE THE JURY, IN THE
ABOVE ENTITLED ACTION,
FIND THE DEFENDANT
THEODORE J. BRISENO NOT GUILTY
OF THE CRIME OF ASSAULT
BY FORCE LIKELY TO PRODUCE
GREAT BODILY INJURY,
AND WITH A DEADLY WEAPON.
WE THE JURY, IN THE
ABOVE ENTITLED ACTION,
FIND THE DEFENDANT
STACEY C. KOON NOT GUILTY
OF THE CRIME
OF ASSAULT BY FORCE LIKELY TO
PRODUCE GREAT BODILY INJURY,
AND WITH A DEADLY WEAPON.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
JURY, ARE THESE YOUR VERDICTS,
SO SAY YOU ONE,
SO SAY YOU ALL?
JURY MEMBERS: YES.
♪ ♪
DAN RATHER: THE JURY IN THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE BRUTALITY
TRIAL HAS JUST
REACHED ITS VERDICTS.
THE FOUR POLICE OFFICERS WHO
WERE VIDEOTAPED REPEATEDLY
BEATING AN UNARMED MAN
WERE FOUND NOT GUILTY ON
ALL BUT ONE COUNT.
PETER JENNINGS: AND NOT ONE
OF THE FOUR POLICE OFFICERS
SEEN ON VIDEOTAPE BEATING
MR. KING A YEAR AGO,
IS GUILTY OF USING
EXCESSIVE FORCE.
THEY'VE ALL BEEN
FOUND NOT GUILTY.
TOM BROKAW: NOT GUILTY
ON ALL BUT ONE COUNT.
PAT DASILVA: AND
JUDGES DECLARED A MISTRIAL
ON ONE COUNT.
REPORTER: THEY'VE ESSENTIALLY
BEEN FOUND NOT GUILTY OF ALL
CHARGES EXCEPT FOR THE ONE
COUNT OF EXCESSIVE FORCE
AGAINST LAURENCE POWELL.
FEMALE REPORTER: THE DISPUTED
VERDICT WAS RETURNED AFTER A
WEEK OF DELIBERATIONS
AT THE END OF A LONG AND
CLOSELY WATCHED TRIAL.
REPORTER: THE JUROR SAID
RACISM DIDN'T ENTER INTO THE
JURY'S DELIBERATIONS.
NONE OF THE JURORS IS BLACK.
THERE WERE TEN WHITES,
ONE ASIAN, AND ONE HISPANIC.
TOM BRADLEY: TODAY, THIS
JURY TOLD THE WORLD THAT WHAT
WE ALL SAW, WITH OUR
OWN EYES, WASN'T A CRIME.
TODAY, THAT JURY ASKED US
TO ACCEPT THE SENSELESS AND
BRUTAL BEATING OF
A HELPLESS MAN.
TODAY, THAT JURY SAID THAT WE
SHOULD TOLERATE SUCH CONDUCT
BY THOSE WHO ARE SWORN
TO PROTECT AND SERVE.
MY FRIENDS, I'M HERE
TO TELL THIS JURY, NO.
NO, OUR EYES DID
NOT DECEIVE US.
WE SAW WHAT WE SAW, AND
WHAT WE SAW WAS A CRIME.
PROTESTOR: YOU GOT
ANOTHER WHITE JURY AH,
SAYING THAT IT'S OKAY
FOR WHITE COPS TO BEAT
UP BLACK PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S RACISM,
AMERICAN STYLE,
AND IT'S BEEN THAT
WAY FROM THE GET.
JOHN SINGLETON: THEY'RE
MAKING IT BAD FOR ALL
THE GOOD COPS.
IF THEY'RE GONNA
LET DIRTY COPS OFF,
HOW'S THAT MAKE A GUY WHO'S
TRYING TO DO HIS JOB FEEL?
WOMAN: MY LITTLE BOY,
HE WANTED TO BE A COP
JUST LIKE HIS FATHER,
BUT AFTER SEEING THAT TAPE,
HE DOESN'T WANT TO
BE THAT ANYMORE.
NOW I HAVE TO
TRAIN HIM NOT TO.
JOHN HATCHER: FOR US
TO TRY TO GO BACK TO TELL
BLACK PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY
THAT JUSTICE IS BLIND,
THEY'LL SAY, YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT IS SO BLIND THAT
THEY CAN'T SEE US.
IT IS SO BLIND TO WHENEVER
SOMETHING HAPPENS TO ONE OF
US, WE GET THE MAX IF WE
DON'T GET KILLED FIRST.
AND SO IT IS BLIND.
WOMAN: WHERE'S MY JUSTICE?
MAN: THERE IS NO JUSTICE.
THERE IS NO JUSTICE.
WOMAN: LETTING, LETTING
A PERSON DRIVE DOWN IN MY
STREETS WITH A
BELLY FULL OF BEER.
REPORTER: BUT YOU
KNOW THAT OUT THERE,
THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT AREN'T GOING
TO BE VERY HAPPY.
HOW WILL YOU RESPOND TO THEM?
WHAT WILL BE YOUR REACTION?
LAURENCE POWELL: OH,
I DON'T THINK I HAVE TO
RESPOND TO THEM.
THEY HAVE TO RESPOND
TO THEMSELVES,
MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS.
THEY HAVE ALL THE FACTS
IN FRONT OF 'EM, I WOULD HOPE.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
SHOULD BASE IT ON.
IT SHOULDN'T BE ANY SORT
OF AN EMOTIONAL THING.
MAN: I'M GLAD THAT YOU GUYS
SHOWED THIS TO THE WORLD TO
LET THEM SEE HOW BLACK PEOPLE
ARE TREATED IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOU KNOW, YOU GUYS
DID NOT RESPECT US.
WE, YOU, YOU FEEL
WE'RE SUBCREATURES.
IF I WENT AND BEAT,
WAIT A MINUTE, SWEETHEART.
IF I WENT AND BEAT YOUR DOG
THE WAY THEY BEAT THIS MAN,
I'D BE IN JAIL.
THESE GUYS ARE GOING
OUT, OUT TO HAVE A DRINK.
REPORTER: WHAT IMAGE OF LOS
ANGELES EMERGES FROM THIS
VERDICT, TO THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY DO YOU THINK?
TOM BRADLEY: WHY DON'T WE
SAY THE REST OF THE WORLD?
PRESIDENT BUSH STANDS UP TO
CHALLENGE LEADERS OF NATIONS
AROUND THE WORLD, UH, TO
AH, RESPECT HUMAN RIGHTS,
AND TO NOT ENGAGE IN A DENIAL
OF THOSE RIGHTS TO CITIZENS.
THEY'RE GONNA LAUGH AT HIM.
THEY'RE GONNA POINT
TO THIS VIDEOTAPE AND
REMEMBER THE
NAME "RODNEY KING."
MAN: IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
MAN 2: I'D LIKE TO SEE ALL THE
BROTHERS IN SOUTH CENTRAL L.A.
GET TOGETHER,
GET OUT IN THE STREET,
STOP KILLING EACH OTHER,
AND LET'S DEAL WITH WHAT
THE REAL PROBLEM IS.
AND WHO IS THE REAL PROBLEM?
REPORTER: WHICH IS?
MAN 2: WHITE PEOPLE.
WHITE PEOPLE.
CROWD: THAT'S RIGHT.
MAN 2: YOU GOT ALL
THE ECONOMIC POWER.
YOU SELLING THE COUNTRY
TO THE JAPANESE.
WE'VE BEEN HERE 437 YEARS
AND DON'T GET NOTHING,
BUT OUR ASS WHOOPED.
AND I'M TIRED OF IT.
WOMAN: YOU KNOW THE FIRST WE
LOOK WE GET BY THE BLACKS?
WHAT ARE YOU DOING
IN OUR COMMUNITY?
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
MAN: "BEANER," A "SPIC."
I'VE HAD COKEHEAD
THROWN AT ME.
THIS IS A PREJUDICED VALLEY.
WOMAN: NO IT'S NOT.
MAN: IT'S A
TRAVESTY OF JUSTICE.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR YEARS, AND,
AND IT'S ABOUT
TIME IT STOPPED.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
WOMAN: THEY GONNA BE SHOOTING
EVERY POLICE THAT GO BY.
THIS IS NOT GONNA END.
THEY JUST STARTED A WAR,
THEY JUST DECLARED A WAR.
WOMAN 2: L.A. SHOULD
GO BACK TO L.A.
WE DON'T WANT YOU OVER HERE.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
STEVEN LERMAN: IT
SENDS A BAD MESSAGE.
IT SAYS IT'S OKAY TO GO
AHEAD AND BEAT SOMEBODY WHEN
THEY'RE DOWN, AND
KICK THE CRAP OUT OF 'EM.
IF IT'S NOT VIDEOTAPED,
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT.
ANOTHER BROTHER OFFICER
WON'T TURN YOU IN,
AND IF A BROTHER OFFICER
DOES TURN YOU IN, DON'T WORRY,
WE'LL GET WHITE JURORS
OR WHOEVER IT TAKES,
AND WE'LL, YOU'LL WALK.
AND YOU'RE PROTECTED
BY THIS SYSTEM.
YOU'RE BACKED UP
THE FACT THAT IT WOULD HAPPEN
HERE, WOULD HAPPEN ANYWHERE,
IS DISGUSTING.
IT'S A GOOD TIME, FOLKS,
IF YOU GOT A PLANE TICKET,
CASH IT IN AND GET
THE HECK OUT OF DODGE.
THIS IS GONNA BE A
BAD PLACE TO LIVE.
WOMAN: THE NEXT PERSON'S GONNA
BE A WHITE PERSON THEN SEE,
THEY GONNA SEE WHAT'S,
UH, WHAT HAPPENS THEN.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
MAN: WHY ARE WE RUNNING?
WHY ARE WE RUNNING?
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
WOMAN: YOU'RE GUILTY.
WOMAN 2: YOU'RE INNOCENT, MAN.
YOU'RE INNOCENT.
KEEP DOING YOUR JOB.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
OFFICER: HEY, I SAID
MOVE THE CAMERAS.
I TELL YOU ONE MORE TIME
THERE'S GONNA BE A PROBLEM.
MOVE OUT, GUYS.
MAN: YOU (BLEEP)
PIECE OF SHIT PIG.
I HOPE YOU BURN IN
HELL, YOU [INAUDIBLE].
YOU PIECE OF SHIT.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
MAN 2: HE'S AN ASSHOLE, MAN.
RACIST PIECE OF SHIT!
HE'S CHEERING HIM ON.
HE'S CHEERING HIM ON, MAN!
THERE AIN'T NO CHEERING HERE.
THAT'S BULLSHIT!
MAN 3: GET A
HAIRCUT, YOU (BLEEP)!
WHAT'S WITH THESE
(BLEEP) PEOPLE?
MAN 4: EVERYONE'S
GOT THEIR OPINION.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
[CHANTING "GUILTY!"]
POLICE SERGEANT: HOLD
YOUR LINE, HOLD YOUR LINE.
HOLD YOUR LINE.
NOBODY LEAVES THE LINE.
MAN: YOU (BLEEP) SELLOUT.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
MAN 2: NO VIOLENCE.
WE CAME HERE TO BE HEARD!
NO VIOLENCE.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
[GLASS BREAKING].
POLICE SERGEANT:
FALL BACK, FALL BACK.
COME ON BACK, FALL BACK.
EASE BACK, COME ON BACK.
DR. MURRAY: NOW EVERY
VOICE, EVERY VOICE,
AT THE TOP OF YOUR VOICE
SAY, "LORD IS ALIVE."
CROWD: LORD IS ALIVE.
DR. MURRAY: LORD IS ALIVE.
DR. MURRAY: LORD
AIN'T DEAD YET.
CROWD: LORD AIN'T DEAD YET.
[APPLAUSE].
♪ ♪
WOMAN: TONIGHT WE MUST TELL
OUR CHILDREN ONE MORE TIME,
STAY COOL.
BE CALM.
THAT FOR AFRICAN-AMERICAN
CHILDREN AND ADULTS,
FREEDOM IS NOT YET A REALITY
IN THE UNITED STATES.
[APPLAUSE].
[CROWD CHANTING "JUSTICE"]
WOMAN: THEY HAVING
CHURCH INSIDE BUT WE FACING
THE FACTS OUT HERE.
TRUTH IN RIGHT.
TRUTH IN RIGHT, REALITY.
NO MORE LIES AND RUMORS.
HENRY ALVARADO: JUST DO
ME A FAVOR AND COOL IT 'CAUSE
I KNOW YOU'RE ANGRY.
I WANT TO SAVE IT, ALRIGHT.
WOMAN: WE'RE COOL, BUT WE
ARE ENRAGED AT THE SAME TIME.
MAN: (BLEEP) THE MEDIA.
MAN 3: SITTING IN THERE
TALKING ABOUT PEACE.
EVERY TIME SOMEBODY
TALK ABOUT PEACE WE GET A
FOOT IN OUR ASS.
MAN 2: THAT'S RIGHT, BRO.
TURN THE OTHER CHEEK
SO THEY CAN KICK IT.
MAN 3: I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT PEACE NO MORE.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY,
HORN HONKING].
MAN: LET'S MAKE SOME NOISE,
LET'S MAKE SOME NOISE.
WAKE UP, BLACK
COMMUNITY, WAKE UP.
[HORN HONKING].
MAN: WAKE UP, BLACK COMMUNITY.
MAN 2: PEOPLE [INAUDIBLE]
TO UNITE AND COME AS ONE AND
TAKE OFF THE RED AND
TAKE OFF THE BLUE AND
PUT IT TOGETHER.
[CROWD CHEERING].
CHANTING "AFRICANS UNITE"]
[INAUDIBLE CROWD CHATTER].
CROWD: [INAUDIBLE] LET'S GO!
[INAUDIBLE] LET'S GO!
OFFICER: OFFICER NEEDS HELP,
WE'RE TAKING BOTTLES AND ROCKS
AT FLORENCE AND NORMANDIE.
[POLICE RADIO CHATTER].
TIMOTHY GOLDMAN:
PUT MY SHIT ON.
DISPATCHER: ALL UNITS,
OFFICER NEEDS HELP FLORENCE
AND NORMANDIE.
TIMOTHY GOLDMAN:
OFFICER DOWN!
I HOPE, UH, HE NEEDS
HELP GETTING HIS ASS KICKED,
BECAUSE, UH,
I DON'T LIKE POLICE.
AND, UH, ME AND AL,
WE'RE THE ROVING REPORTERS.
DISPATCHER: LOOKS LIKE
IT'S FLORENCE AND NORMANDIE.
TIMOTHY GOLDMAN:
FLORENCE AND NORMANDIE.
HERE WE COME.
[HELICOPTER].
HELICOPTER PILOT:
ATTENTION NUMBER #3, MA'AM.
WE'RE ABOVE THE
LOCATION RIGHT NOW.
UH, WE GOT MANY OFFICERS
AND MANY PEOPLE RUNNING.
TIMOTHY GOLDMAN: WHAT'S
GOING ON, WHAT'S GOING ON?
LOUDSPEAKER: WE NEED ALL
YOU GUYS TO STEP BACK.
WE NEED ALL YOU
GUYS TO STEP BACK.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
WOMAN: LEAVE HIM ALONE.
HEY, LEAVE HIM ALONE.
POLICE OFFICER: RELAX, RELAX!
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
MAN: (BLEEP) THAT SHIT, MAN.
GET THAT RIOT GEAR.
HIT ME, (BLEEP), HIT ME.
MAN 2: I WANT ALL YOU
(BLEEP) TO KNOW ONE THING.
IT'S WAR ON THE
STREETS, (BLEEP)!
IT'S WAR ON THE STREETS.
WOMAN: HER UP, I KNOW!
POLICE RADIO: I WANT
EVERYBODY OUT OF HERE.
FLORENCE AND NORMANDIE,
EVERYBODY GET OUT NOW.
DISPATCHER: LIEUTENANT
IS REQUESTING EVERYONE OUT OF
THE AREA OF FLORENCE
AND NORMANDIE.
EVERYONE, OUT OF THE AREA,
FLORENCE AND NORMANDIE.
LOUDSPEAKER: IT'S
NOT WORTH IT.
LET'S GO.
IT'S NOT WORTH IT.
LET'S GO, FIGHTING'S
NOT WORTH IT.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
MAN: BLACK MAN, YOU OUGHT
TO BE ASHAMED OF YOURSELF.
[SIRENS].
MAN: THESE ARE
ALL MY PEOPLE, MAN.
BART BARTHOLOMEW:
OH, I SAW, I SAW.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
WOMAN: HOW YOU
FEEL, HOW YOU FEEL?
HOW YOU FEEL, HUH?
WHY DO YOU [INAUDIBLE]?
[INAUDIBLE RIOT BANTER].
CHARLES MUHAMMAD: I'M ANGRY,
BUT I'M NOT SURPRISED.
FOR OVER FOUR HUNDRED YEARS,
OUR PEOPLE HAVE SUFFERED.
NOT ONLY CIVIL RIGHTS, BUT
THE RIGHT TO BE A HUMAN BEING.
[APPLAUSE].
DON'T FALL VICTIM
TO THE DIVISION.
YOU SEE US UNITED
FROM ALL A CROSS-SECTION
OF THE COMMUNITY TODAY,
BECAUSE ONE OF OUR BROTHERS
HAS BEEN UNJUSTLY BEATEN,
AND IT HAS BEEN
JUSTIFIED BY A JURY,
THAT SHOWS US THAT WE
CAN'T GET JUSTICE IN AMERICA.
HOW LONG DO WE HAVE
TO SEE THESE THINGS?
HOW LONG BEFORE
WE COME TOGETHER IN
LOVE FOR OURSELVES?
HOW MANY MORE RODNEY
KINGS DOES IT HAVE TO BE?
HOW MANY MORE LATASHA
HARLINS DOES IT HAVE TO BE?
[CROWD CHEERING AND APPLAUSE].
RIOTERS: THAT'S RIGHT,
BROTHERS, (BLEEP) 'EM UP.
WE GONNA (BLEEP) UP WHITE BOYS.
YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT, LET
THE MEXICANS PASS THROUGH.
NO MEXICANS, NO MEXICANS.
(BLEEP) WITH THE
BUDDHA HEADS AND (BLEEP)
WITH THEM WHITE BOYS.
[GLASS SHATTERS].
REPORTER: I'M GOING
LIVE IN A SECOND.
STAND BY, EVERYBODY.
KEEP A LIVE PICTURE, OKAY?
[CAR HORN HONKS].
RIOTERS: YOU BETTER GO.
Y'ALL BETTER TURN
THE (BLEEP) AROUND.
MAN: (BLEEP) THE WHITE MAN!
YEAH, (BLEEP),
THIS IS HISTORY.
(BLEEP) Y'ALL, WE KILLIN'.
NEWS ANCHOR: APPARENTLY
GROUPS OF YOUTHS ARE ON
THE STREETS IN
SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES.
THERE ARE REPORTS
THAT THEY ARE THROWING
ROCKS AND BOTTLES.
KIM: LET'S GET THE LATEST
ON THE SITUATION NOW AND
GO TO NEWS COPTER 13.
BOB TUR: KIM, YOU'RE
LOOKING AT A LIVE PICTURE.
THERE'S BEEN A MINI-RIOT
AT THIS LOCATION.
TOM'S LIQUOR STORE HAS
BEEN LOOTED AT THIS POINT.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
MAN: YEAH, YEAH, YEAH, GO.
TURN, TURN,
TURN, YEAH, YEAH.
RIOTERS: Y'ALL THANK KING!
(BLEEP) THE POLICE.
(BLEEP) THEM (BLEEP)!
YEAH!
BOB TUR: HANG ON, I'M GETTING
A REPORT FROM THE POLICE.
GO AHEAD.
OKAY, THEY'VE NOW, THERE'S
NOW BEEN A TACTICAL ALERT
FOR THIS AREA.
THEY'VE SET UP A COMMAND
POST AND THAT OFFICERS HAVE
BEEN ORDERED TO STAY
OUT OF THIS AREA.
[SIRENS].
MAN ON RADIO: NORMANDIE
AND 71ST, WE NEED HELP.
WOMAN ON RADIO: THERE'S A
RIOT SITUATION IN THE AREA.
ADVISE UNITS NOT TO RESPOND.
REPORTER: WE UNDERSTAND, UH,
WE HAVE A HELICOPTER SHOT NOW.
UH, THIS IS, UH, OVER
THE COMMAND CENTER THAT'S
AT 54TH AND, UH, VAN NESS.
YOU CAN SEE
CERTAINLY THERE, UH,
THE CONCENTRATION
OF POLICE VEHICLES.
MAN ON RADIO: THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT IS AWARE OF THE
SITUATION AT FLORENCE
AND NORMANDIE.
THEY ARE HOLDING BACK
ON THEIR RESPONSE.
MAN 2 ON RADIO: FOR THE
PRESENT TIME WE ARE NOT GONNA
GO IN THAT AREA FOR ANYBODY.
BOB TUR: WE'RE WORKING A
NUMBER OF RADIOS ABOARD NEWS
COPTER 13.
WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE
HAVE PEOPLE ABOARD THAT ARE
RELAYING INFORMATION TO
THE POLICE HELICOPTERS AND
TO THE EMERGENCY OPERATION
CENTER IN THE CITY.
WE'RE ALSO SHOWING A LIVE
PICTURE THAT THEY'RE SEEING.
THEY KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON DOWN HERE.
[INAUDIBLE YELLING
AND COMMOTION].
MAN: (BLEEP)
OUT OF HERE, MAN.
(BLEEP)!
BOB TUR: THEY'RE ATTACKING
EVERYONE THAT COMES TO A STOP
HERE AT THIS INTERSECTION.
ROCKS AND BOTTLES BEING
THROWN AT ANOTHER CAR.
THEY'RE NOW PULLING
THE DOOR OFF THE CAR.
IF YOU ARE IN THIS AREA, YOU
DON'T WANT TO COME DOWN HERE.
[GLASS BREAKING].
BOB TUR: THERE'S A VAN
COMING UNDER ATTACK.
NOW THEY'RE PULLING
THE DRIVER OUT.
THEY'RE KICKING THE DRIVER
AND BEATING THE DRIVER.
ALL THIS GUY DID
WAS ENTER THIS AREA.
THAT'S HIS ONLY CRIME.
HIT THE SIREN, GUYS.
NEWS ANCHOR: OH MY GOSH!
OH MY.
NEWS ANCHOR 2: OH, THESE ARE.
NEWS ANCHOR: ABSOLUTELY
BRUTAL ATTACK.
BOB TUR: TERRIBLE!
TERRIBLE PICTURES.
[INAUDIBLE STREET NOISE].
RIOTER: NO (BLEEP)
PITY FOR THE WHITE MAN.
NO PITY FOR THE WHITE MAN.
LAY YOUR WHITE ASS DOWN.
THAT'S HOW (BLEEP)
RODNEY KING FELT WHITE BOY!
THAT'S HOW RODNEY KING,
DON'T HELP HIS WHITE ASS!
HEY, DON'T HELP HIS ASS.
BOB BRILL: THE MAN IS UP NOW.
HIS CLOTHES ARE TORN, HE'S
STILL BLEEDING ALL OVER,
BUT HE'S TRYING TO GET
BACK INTO HIS TRUCK.
HE IS GETTING BACK
INTO HIS TRUCK.
I HOPE HE HAS
ENOUGH POWER TO,
ON HIS OWN TO JUST
GET OUT OF THE AREA.
I'M A NEWS REPORTER.
MAN: OH GOD!
HELP, HELP, OH, GOD, HELP!
[INAUDIBLE STREET NOISE].
WOMAN:(BLEEP) IT DON'T
EVEN AMAZE ME NO MORE.
WOMAN 2: HERE'S TO
RODNEY KING AND LATASHA HARLINS!
♪ ♪
MAN: HE'S BLACK
NOW, HE'S BLACK NOW.
WOMAN: IS HE DEAD?
MAN: HE AIN'T DEAD
YET BUT HE GONNA DIE.
THEY SPRAY PAINTED HIS NOSE,
PUT IT ALL IN HIS MOUTH.
HE'S GONNA DIE.
HE NEEDS IMMEDIATE HELP.
[HELICOPTER].
♪ ♪
[PROTESTORS
CHANTING INAUDIBLY].
REPORTER:
I CAN'T HEAR A THING.
LINDA BREAKSTONE:
WHO AM I GOING LIVE WITH?
NETWORK OR?
REPORTER: YES, YES, I'M READY.
CALVIN, WE'RE
READY TO GO LIVE.
LINDA BREAKSTONE: YOU HAVE ME
BUT ARE YOU, ARE WE BACK NOW?
OKAY, HERE WE GO, UM.
WE'RE GONNA GO IN DEEPER AND
SHOW YOU AT THE CORE OF THIS
THING WHAT'S GOING ON.
LET'S GO THIS WAY.
LET'S GO.
CROWD: NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE.
NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE.
MAN: THERE'S NOT
CRIPS DOWN HERE.
THERE'S NO BLOODS DOWN HERE.
THERE'S JUST CONCERNED
CITIZENS DOWN HERE THAT DON'T
LIKE THE WAY THE
SYSTEM IS DONE.
LINDA BREAKSTONE: WHAT,
COULD YOU TELL ME?
MAN: THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
REPORTER: WE'VE GOT A CROWD
OF ABOUT 400 PEOPLE AT LEAST
OVER HERE, VERY ANGRY PEOPLE.
THEY ARE THROWING SIGNS.
THEY HAVE TAKEN OVER LOS
ANGELES STREET AND AGAIN,
THE SITUATION IS
VERY VOLATILE.
PEOPLE KEEP ON
TAUNTING THE OFFICERS,
THROWING THINGS AT THEM.
WOMAN: (BLEEP) YOU.
HAL: RON, IS THIS
AN ORGANIZED, UH,
DEMONSTRATION OR?
RON: NO, I THINK, HAL,
I THINK IT STARTED OUT AS
AN ORGANIZED DEMONSTRATION
AND, UH, AND THEN IT
GREW AND GREW AND, UH, NOW,
NOW IT HAS BEEN,
FOR THE PAST HOUR OR SO,
PRETTY MUCH A STANDOFF HERE.
CROWD: NO PEACE, NO JUSTICE,
NO PEACE, NO JUSTICE.
REPORTER: I WANT TO GO NOW.
[PROTESTORS
CHANTING INAUDIBLY].
REPORTER: OKAY, MA, MICHAEL,
THINGS HAVE ESCALATED
DRAMATICALLY IN THE
LAST FIFTEEN MINUTES.
THAT IS THE THIRD FLAG
THAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT
THEY HAVE BURNED.
REPORTER 2: WHERE YOU'RE
LOOKING AT ONE OF THE PARKER
CENTER GUARD STATIONS.
ONE OF THE GUARD STATIONS,
THEY HAVE TAKEN IT OVER,
THEY ARE BREAKING THE WINDOWS.
WE ARE ASKING PEOPLE TO
STAY OUT OF THIS AREA.
REPORTER 3:
POLICE OFFICERS TRYING TO
SEAL OFF THE STREETS.
UH, THE GROUP BASICALLY
JUST MARCHING RIGHT DOWN
THE MIDDLE OF THE STREET.
REPORTER: IT, IT IS
A MULTIRACIAL CROWD.
IT IS NOT, UH,
PREDOMINANTLY ANY COLOR.
THERE'S A FELLOW WHO'S
LIGHTING THE TREES, IS NE NOT?
REPORTER 3: YES,
YES THAT'S WHAT WE SAW.
REPORTER: ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH, GOING ALONG
BLOCK TO BLOCK.
REPORTER 3: AND
HERE WE CAN SEE HE'S.
REPORTER: AND
NOBODY'S STOPPING HIM.
HE, ER, ONE TREE
AFTER ANOTHER.
REPORTER 3: THESE BEARDED
PALMS UH, WITH THE,
THE DEAD FRONDS
HANGING DOWN AH,
GREAT FUEL FOR AN ARSONIST.
[INAUDIBLE RIOT BANTER].
RIOTERS: HEY, YO, YO!
BURN THEM, BURN
THEM, BURN THEM.
RIGHT HERE, RIGHT HERE, RIGHT
HERE, RIGHT HERE, RIGHT HERE!
BURN GATES, BURN GATES,
BURN GATES, BURN GATES!
BURN THIS MOTHER.
BURN THAT SHIT.
BURN THEM, BURN THEM
OUT OF THE CITY.
[INAUDIBLE RIOT BANTER].
REPORTER: NOW THEY'RE
TURNING THIS OVER.
[CHEERING].
RIOTERS: NO PEACE, NO JUSTICE,
NO PEACE, NO JUSTICE,
NO PEACE, NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE,
NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE,
NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE.
WOMAN: NO JUSTICE, NO PEACE.
SHUT THE CITY DOWN.
MAN: (BLEEP) UNCLE TOM,
(BLEEP) UNCLE TOM.
(BLEEP) HIM,
WOMAN: (BLEEP)
THE COURT BUILDING!
THIS IS WHERE SO MUCH
CORRUPTION STARTS FROM.
THIS COURT NEEDS
TO BE BURNED DOWN!
[INAUDIBLE RIOT BANTER].
REPORTER: I TALKED TO SOME
OF THE OFFICERS A LITTLE
WHILE AGO AND THEY,
THEY REALLY DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO DO RIGHT NOW.
AND THEY, THERE WERE
TV CAMERAS ALL OVER.
THERE ARE PEOPLE
ALL OVER AND, UH,
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
REALLY KNOWS WHAT TO DO AND
HOW TO GET
THIS UNDER CONTROL.
[INAUDIBLE RIOT BANTER].
HELICOPTER PILOT: [INAUDIBLE]
CIVIC CENTER, RIGHT TURN 1.2.
REPORTER: STEPHANIE,
IS THAT YOU?
DO YOU WANT TO CHANGE
THAT TO HOW WIDESPREAD IS,
IS THE VIOLENCE BECAUSE IT'LL
BE HARD TO TALK ABOUT, OKAY?
WELL AT THIS EVENING,
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE ABOUT TWENTY FIRES BURNING,
MOSTLY IN
SOUTH CENTRAL LOS ANGELES.
THIS IS A PREDOMINANTLY
BLACK AREA OF THE CITY.
BOB TUR: THIS IS A
SUPER SWAPMEET LOCATION.
SOMEONE, ACTUALLY A GROUP OF
OVER 100 PEOPLE WENT INTO THIS
LOCATION AND LOOTED IT.
AND EVERY TIME THEY GO
IN AND LOOT, AFTER THEY,
THEY'RE DONE LOOTING, THEY
SET FIRE TO THE STRUCTURE.
MAN: I'M TIRED OF WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY.
THEY SHOT LATASHA HARLINS.
THEY TOOK OUT MY BOY RODNEY
KING, BEAT HIM ON THE STREETS.
WHAT YOU NEED MORE
THAN VIDEOTAPE?
WE GONNA TAKE
OUT EVERYONE THAT'S GONNA
TAKE US OUT FIRST.
MAN 2: GO, GO.
MAN 3: CLACK, CLACK,
CLACK, CLACK, CLACK.
REPORTER: WE'RE HEARING FOR
THE FIRST TIME TONIGHT FROM
DARYL GATES, WHO IS
HOLDING A NEWS CONFERENCE.
LET'S GO TO HIM LIVE.
DARYL GATES: ONCE
AGAIN, I THINK, UH,
MOST OF IT'S
CONCENTRATED AT SOUTH CENTRAL
LOS ANGELES AREA.
BUT, UH, PROBLEM IS YOU FIND
MANY LOCATIONS WHERE THERE ARE
NO OFFICERS AND, UH,
THAT NEEDS TO BE CORRECTED
AND WE'RE TRYING TO DO
THAT AS QUICK AS WE CAN.
[SIRENS].
MAN ON RADIO: UNREPORTED
STRUCTURE FIRE FOR LIGHT
4-64 DASH [INAUDIBLE].
MAN 2 ON RADIO: WE'RE TAKING
SOME PRETTY HEAVY SLACK ON
ADAMS ABOUT HOBART.
THERE ARE THREE
SEPARATE STRUCTURE FIRES.
MAN 3: WE'VE JUST
BEEN TAKEN OUT.
WE'VE GOT BOTTLES
THROUGH THE WINDOW.
UH, ONLY...
MAN 4 ON RADIO: UH, NEED,
UH, SOME PD IN THAT AREA AND
SOME FIRE
COMPANIES ASSIGNED.
MAN 5 ON RADIO: WE
HAVE A FIREMAN SHOT.
WE HAVE A FIREMAN SHOT.
WE NEED HELP IMMEDIATELY.
ROGER, LAPD.
WE HAVE A NEED OF
[INAUDIBLE] WITH A GURNEY.
BOB TUR: THEY'RE
DISPATCHING LAPD UNITS AH,
ALONG WITH ALL FIRE TRUCKS
THAT RESPOND TO MAJOR
EMERGENCY BLAZES
FOR OUR PROTECTION.
BUT UH, WITH RESPECT TO
TRYING TO GET LAPD SERVICE FOR
ANYTHING ELSE, FOLKS,
YOU'RE ON YOUR OWN DOWN THERE.
[ALARM, SIRENS].
ROSS BECKER: THERE
ARE FIRES BURNING.
THERE ARE PEOPLE BEING
BEATEN, THERE IS LOOTING.
IT IS A DANGEROUS NIGHT
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
[EXPLOSION]
♪ ♪
PETE WILSON: I'M
ADVISED THAT, UH,
THERE IS SOMEONE FROM THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE ON
THE WAY OVER TO
ACCEPT THIS PROCLAMATION
OF A STATE EMERGENCY,
OF A STATE OF EMERGENCY
FOR LOS ANGELES CITY
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
THIS IS, UH, IN RESPONSE TO
A REQUEST BY MAYOR BRADLEY.
AS A RESULT OF THE
DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAVE HAD,
THERE WILL BE AS MANY AS 750
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROLMEN.
ADDITIONALLY, WE HAVE
MADE AVAILABLE SOME
2,000 NATIONAL GUARDSMEN.
THEY ARE ON STANDBY,
PREPARED TO, UH, MOVE.
TRANSPORT HAS BEEN ARRANGED.
AND IT IS OUR PURPOSE HERE AT
THE STATE GOVERNMENT LEVEL TO
RESTORE LAW AND ORDER, AND
TO MINIMIZE THE DANGER TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE AREA.
THIS IS A MATTER THAT NEEDS TO
BE SETTLED IN THE COURTS AND
NOT IN THE STREETS.
THANK YOU.
CROWD: WHAT DO YOU WANT?
JUSTICE.
WHEN DO YOU WANT IT?
NOW.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
JUSTICE?
WHEN DO YOU WANT IT?
NOW.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
JUSTICE?
WHEN DO YOU WANT IT?
NOW.
JIM: WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
ARE SCRAMBLING AT THIS VERY
MOMENT, UH, TO PRODUCE A
STATEMENT FROM PRESIDENT BUSH.
NOBODY EXPECTED THAT VERDICT
THE WAY IT CAME DOWN.
THERE'S NOTHING REALLY THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE CAN DO ABOUT
THAT VERDICT BUT
IT DOES PRESENT A HUGE
POLITICAL PROBLEM.
MANY CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS
THOUGHT THAT PRESIDENT BUSH
HAS BEEN WEAK ON CIVIL
RIGHTS, CIVIL RIGHTS PROMISES.
REPORTER: HAVE YOU HAD ANY
DISCUSSIONS WITH PRESIDENT BUSH,
EITHER ON THE TELEPHONE,
OR HAS THERE BEEN ANY FORM?
MAXINE WATERS: PRESIDENT
BUSH DOES NOT TALK TO US.
UH, LET'S, LET'S, LET'S, LET'S,
LET'S BE STRAIGHT ABOUT THIS.
AH, WE HAVE NO ACCESS
TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE HAD ONE MEETING SINCE
I HAVE BEEN IN CONGRESS,
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
IT WAS PRO FORMA,
IT WAS COURTESY,
BUT THERE IS NO RELATIONSHIP.
MAN: IS THAT WHO WE THOUGHT?
MAN 2: I THINK SO, YEAH.
JIM: ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
SAY THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HAD IN FACT
LAUNCHED A CIVIL RIGHTS
INVESTIGATION INTO THE RODNEY
KING BEATING BUT ONCE STATE
CHARGES WERE BROUGHT THEY
SORT OF PUT THAT ON HOLD.
NOW IT'S UNCLEAR AT THIS
MOMENT EXACTLY WHERE
THAT INVESTIGATION STANDS.
FAITH?
FAITH: IT WOULD ALMOST
SEEM AT THIS POINT, JIM,
THAT THEY'D HAVE TO
PICK IT UP AGAIN.
YOU CANNOT IGNORE THAT
ALL OF THIS IS COMING
IN A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION YEAR.
GOV. CLINTON: YOU KNOW
THAT I DON'T THINK
HE'S DONE ENOUGH BUT I,
BUT I THINK WE HAVE
HAD TOO MUCH DIVISION AND
TOO LITTLE HARMONY.
I THINK THERE'S BEEN TOO
LITTLE EFFORT TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER ACROSS RACIAL LINES.
THIS IS A HUMAN PROBLEM.
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
DON'T TRUST EACH OTHER AND
DON'T TRUST THE SYSTEM.
AND THE POLITICAL SYSTEM HAS
TOO OFTEN DIVIDED PEOPLE BY
RACE AND THAT IS THE URGENT
TASK FOR AMERICA TODAY.
OUR DIVERSITY WILL
EITHER BE OUR UNDOING,
OR THE SOURCE OF OUR
GREATEST STRENGTH.
MAXINE WATERS: I AM ANGRY, AND
I HAVE A RIGHT TO THAT ANGER,
AND THE PEOPLE OUT THERE
HAVE A RIGHT TO THAT ANGER.
WE DON'T WANT ANYBODY KILLED.
NONE OF US BELIEVE
IN VIOLENCE.
BUT THERE ARE SOME
ANGRY PEOPLE IN AMERICA,
AND YOUNG BLACK
MALES, IN MY DISTRICT,
ARE FEELING AT THIS MOMENT,
IF THEY COULD NOT GET A
CONVICTION, WITH THE RODNEY
KING VIDEO AVAILABLE TO THE
JURORS, THAT THERE CAN
BE NO JUSTICE IN AMERICA.
[APPLAUSE].
♪ ♪
ERIC "RICO" REED: 102.3 KJLH,
HERE IN LOS ANGELES AND, UH,
WE'RE DISCUSSING ALL THE
VIOLENCE AND THE AFTERMATH AND
THE DIRECTIONS TO GO AS FAR
AS THIS AH, INCIDENT HERE.
VENT YOUR ANGER,
YOUR FRUSTRATION, YOUR,
YOUR HARD FEELINGS.
NOT OUT IN THE STREETS,
NOT BREAKING WINDOWS,
NOT LOOTING, NOT RIOTING,
BUT YOU KNOW, IT, IT,
I GUESS JUST SOME PEOPLE
SAY, JUST PUNCH ON ME.
PUNCH ON THE RADIO STATION.
TALK TO US OVER THE LINES.
LET, LET'S GO BACK TO THE
PHONE LINES AND LET'S SEE HOW
YOU FEEL THIS MORNING.
CALLER: YEAH, UM, I FEEL
REAL FRUSTRATED, YOU KNOW,
BECAUSE, UH, I, I DON'T
HAVE NO NEIGHBORHOOD NO MORE.
CALLER 2: THIS IS
NOT THE WAY FOR US TO
VENT OUR FRUSTRATION.
ERIC "RICO" REED: YES.
CALLER 2: THIS IS WHAT
THEY EXPECT US TO DO.
ROBERT: I'VE BEEN LISTENING
TO KJLH ALL MY LIFE AND
I ONLY HAVE THREE WORDS
FOR, UH, WHAT'S HAPPENING,
AND THOSE ARE THE SAME THREE
WORDS THAT WAS UTTERED DURING
THE 1965 RIOTS.
ERIC "RICO" REED: AND YOU'RE
GONNA SAY THOSE BAD WORDS, HUH?
ROBERT: BURN, BABY, BURN.
ERIC "RICO" REED:
YEAH, THAT'S A...
DJ 2: THANK YOU, ROBERT.
MAN: I SAW IT ON TV.
WE COME DOWN HERE AND
IT'S JUST BLAZING.
REPORTER: AND THIS
IS YOUR AUNT'S STORE?
MAN: YES.
REPORTER: AND WAS IT
A LIQUOR STORE HERE OR?
MAN: NO, THIS WAS
A 99 CENT STORE.
REPORTER: AH-HA.
MAN: AND SHE HAS ANOTHER
STORE ON CRENSHAW AND
THAT ONE IS GONE.
IT'S TERRIBLE,
ABSOLUTELY TERRIBLE.
BUT WHAT CAN YOU SAY?
THEY SAID IT ALL YESTERDAY
AND THIS IS THE OUTCOME OF IT.
AND THIS IS THE
OUTCOME OF THIS.
MAN: YOU ARE LISTENING
TO A SPECIAL NEWS REPORT
ON AM 1580, RADIO KOREA.
SOME NEWS JUST CAME IN, KFWB
RADIO HAS REPORTED THAT MORE
DAMAGE WAS DONE TO KOREAN
BUSINESSES THAN ANY OTHERS
DURING THE RIOTS.
THE REPORT SAYS THAT THE
REASON MAY BE THE CONFLICT
BETWEEN THE KOREAN
AND BLACK COMMUNITIES.
MAN: I DON'T BLAME ANY OTHER
PEOPLE, ANY OTHER RACE,
ANY OTHER COLORS.
JUST, IT HAPPENED.
IT HAPPENED.
THAT'S IT.
WE'RE GONNA BUILD HERE AGAIN.
WE WANT TO KEEP OUR
GOOD INTENTION, CONTINUES.
AND, UH, THAT'S IT.
WE, WE LIVE HERE AND
WE, WE WILL LIVE HERE
AND, UH, [SIGHS].
REPORTER: I UNDERSTAND.
REPORTER 2: THE CITY
IS STILL OFFICIALLY UNDER A
STATE OF EMERGENCY.
THE CITY COUNCIL IS GOING
TO MEET AND DISCUSS HOW TO
PROCEED FROM HERE.
JOHN FERRARO: THE PURPOSE OF
THIS MEETING IS TO DISCUSS THE
NECESSARY ACTION RELATIVE TO
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES DECLARED
BY THE MAYOR ON APRIL 29TH.
OKAY, UH, MR. HOLDEN.
MR. HOLDEN: UH,
MR. PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS,
I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD FROM
EACH OF MY COLLEAGUES BEFORE I
ARRIVED AND CERTAINLY YOU'VE
SEEN THEM ON TV ASKING FOR
CALM AND REGRETTING THE
TRAGEDY THAT TOOK PLACE LAST
NIGHT AND CONTINUING
IN OUR CITY.
THE QUESTION IS, UH,
HOW DO WE STOP IT?
WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD
IDEA IT IS LIKELY TO OCCUR,
AND IT WILL UNLESS
WE HAVE A PRESENCE.
BUT YOU GOT TO START DEPLOYING
RIGHT NOW, I TELL YOU.
HANDWRITING'S ON THE WALL.
DJ: I CAN'T REALLY TELL
'CAUSE WE'RE ON THE RADIO AND
I CAN BARELY
SEE THE TELEVISION.
ARE PEOPLE STILL
LOOTING AT THIS TIME?
DJ 2: YES, THEY ARE.
I SEEN THEM WHEN
I WAS COMING IN TO WORK.
THEY'RE STILL GOING IN
TO STORES AND THEY'RE STILL
TAKING THINGS.
DJ: INCREDIBLE, INCREDIBLE.
DJ 2: AND LAUGHING.
MAN: MAN, GETTING STUFF,
MAN, GETTING STUFF.
GO IN THERE AND
FIND YOUR SIZE, MAN.
GETTING STUFF.
REPORTER: WHILE THE, THE
LOOTING SEEMS TO CONTINUE
UNABATED, UH, THE MOOD AT
LEAST, UH, SEEMS TO BE, UH,
VERY CALM TODAY.
LOOK AT RIGHT THROUGH THERE.
IT SAYS "FACTORY DIRECT SALE."
THIS IS THE BIGGEST SALE
THEY'VE PROBABLY EVER SEEN.
IT'S LIKE PEOPLE ARE
LOOTING ANYTHING THEY CAN
GET THEIR HANDS ON.
HERE'S A GUY WITH
A PLANT, EVEN,
COMING RIGHT OUT THE
FRONT WINDOW AND TAKING OFF.
MAN: I'VE BEEN TAKING
PICTURES OF ALL THIS.
THIS IS EXCITING.
IT'S WRONG, BUT IT'S EXCITING.
BUT YOU KNOW SOMETHING?
IT'S KIND OF ORDERLY.
IT'S KIND OF ORDERLY IN A WAY.
MAN 2: OH, EXCUSE ME.
MAN: I'M TELLING
YOU, IT'S, IT'S AMA,
LET ME GET THIS SHOT HERE.
IT'S AMAZING.
REPORTER 2:
WHERE ARE THE POLICE?
WHERE ARE ALL THE
POLICE THAT CHIEF GATES SAID
WOULD BE READY FOR THIS?
MAN: UH, CHIEF GATES?
DARYL GATES: UH, YES.
JUST TO, UH, EMPHASIZE,
UH, OUR DEPLOYMENT, UH,
WILL INCREASE SUBSTANTIALLY
AND, UH, WE HOPE THAT THAT,
UH, WILL, UH,
SATISFY THE NEED.
BOB TUR: NOW, NOW
THERE ARE SOME POLICE,
NOW EVERYONE'S RUNNING.
HERE, HERE THE
POLICE ARE COMING.
LOOK AT THAT.
THERE MUST BE TWO OR
THREE DOZEN PEOPLE.
THEY'RE STILL COMING OUT
OF THAT STORE RIGHT NOW.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PEOPLE
FIT IN THAT STORE BUT THEY'RE
ALL RUNNING OUT
BECAUSE THERE'S THE POLICE
FINALLY MOVING IN.
THE POLICE CAN'T ARREST
THIS MANY PEOPLE.
THEY JUST GO RUNNING
WITH THEIR MERCHANDISE AND
THE POLICE REALLY AREN'T
RUNNING AFTER THEM.
THEY CAN'T RUN AFTER THEM.
POLICE OFFICER: WE JUST
DON'T ENOUGH PEOPLE TO DO IT.
AS SOON AS WE CHASE THEM
AWAY, THEY COME RIGHT BACK.
TOM BRADLEY: IT'S MY JUDGMENT
THAT THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
OF THOSE WHO ARE ENGAGED IN
THAT UNLAWFUL ACTIVITY NOW ARE
NOT THE LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS OF THIS COMMUNITY,
BUT THOSE WHO ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF AN OPPORTUNITY.
REPORTER: WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WOMAN: I DON'T KNOW.
REPORTER:
ARE YOU EMBARRASSED?
DON'T YOU KNOW
THIS IS ILLEGAL?
WHY DID YOU DO THIS?
MAN: I DON'T KNOW.
BECAUSE IT'S FREE.
REPORTER: 'CAUSE IT'S FREE?
MAN: YEAH.
REPORTER: DON'T YOU
KNOW IT'S WRONG?
MAN: NAH.
REPORTER: YOU DON'T CARE?
MAN: I DON'T CARE.
MAN 2: HONESTLY, WHAT IS
BEING DONE NOW IS NOT GOOD.
IF THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT HAD PAID KING
HIS RIGHTS, AS THE
CITIZEN THAT HE IS,
WHAT'S HAPPENING TODAY
WOULD NOT BE HAPPENING.
THE BLAME SHOULD BE
PUT ON THE GOVERNMENT.
REPORTER: WHERE ARE THE
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROMISED?
WHY DO WE NOT SEE THEM?
DAN: BILL, WHY HASN'T
THE NATIONAL GUARD
BEEN CALLED OUT?
BILL: THAT'S A MYSTERY, DAN.
UH, WE HAVE, UH, HAD REPORTS
THAT SEVERAL HUNDRED ARE IN
THE AREA AND WE EXPECT TO
SEE AND HEAR FROM THEM SOON.
REPORTER: BUT I UNDERSTAND
THAT, UH, IDEA THAT, UH,
THEY COULD MAKE THINGS WORSE
BUT THEN YOU COULD SAY THAT
ABOUT THE POLICE TOO.
I MEAN, HOW MUCH WORSE
DOES IT NEED TO GET?
[INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
[WOMAN CRYING].
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
MAN: (BLEEP) THEM,
(BLEEP) THAT (BLEEP)!
WOMAN 2: MAN, COME ON, MAN.
GIVE IT TO HER.
WHEN HE GOT HERE EARLIER
THIS MORNING 'CAUSE I
CAME UP HERE
TO GET MY STUFF.
MAN: THEY STEALING
CLOTHES UP IN HERE.
WOMAN 3: THEY GOT MY CLOTHES.
MAN: THEY GOT MY CLOTHES.
OH, MAN.
WOMAN 2: CALM DOWN.
BILL: THEY GOT THE TICKETS.
THEY HAVE THE TICKETS
SO JUST CALM DOWN.
WOMAN 2: YOU KNOW,
THEY HAVE OUR STUFF.
YOU KNOW, AND.
BILL: THEY'RE UPSET.
MAN: THEY GOT A LOT OF MONEY.
[WOMAN CRYING].
[SIRENS].
[WOMAN CRIES].
MAN: WHY IS THIS
TRAGEDY HAPPENING TO US?
COULD IT BE THAT
GOD IS PUNISHING US?
WOMAN: ACCORDING
TO THE POLICE,
THIS MIGHT NOT BE THE END.
WE WILL HAVE TO STAY
ALERT THIS WEEKEND.
WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO?
HOW ARE WE TO PROTECT
OUR BUSINESSES?
MAN: CAN YOU TELL ME
WHERE YOUR STORE IS?
WOMAN: IT'S AT 84TH
STREET AND VERMONT.
MAN: SUPER SWAP MEET, YES?
SO YOU CAN OWN A
CLOTHING STORE IN THERE?
YES, IS IT ON FIRE?
MAN 2: IT'S BURNING.
WOMAN: IS THERE ANY WAY FOR
A FIRE TRUCK TO GET THERE?
MAN: SO FAR, I DON'T SEE ANY.
MAYBE THE FIREFIGHTERS
ARE COVERING OTHER AREAS
AT THIS MOMENT?
WOMAN: WHAT CAN WE DO?
THAT'S OUR LIVELIHOOD!
DAVID JACKSON: WE HAVE
A FIRE THAT'S BROKEN OUT IN
KOREATOWN HERE
ACROSS WESTERN AVENUE.
PAT: HAVE THERE BEEN ANY KINDS
OF DISTURBANCES IN KOREATOWN?
I THINK THIS IS THE
FIRST WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS
KIND OF ACTIVITY.
DAVID JACKSON: YES,
THAT'S RIGHT, PAT.
THIS HAS JUST ERUPTED.
PAT: I DON'T SEE ANY OFFICIAL
FIREFIGHTERS, ANY ENGINES.
ARE THERE ANY IN THE AREA?
DAVID JACKSON: NO,
NO FIREFIGHTERS HERE.
MAN: THE BUSINESSES WHERE THE
OWNERS SHUT DOWN AND EVACUATED
GENERALLY SUFFERED EXTENSIVE
DAMAGE WHILE THOSE WHERE THE
OWNERS STAYED AND PROTECTED
THEIR SHOPS HAD ALMOST NONE.
DAVID KIM: YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO PROTECT YOURSELVES AND
YOUR BUSINESSES, AND
WHEN ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY,
YOU CAN ARM YOURSELVES.
THE LAWS OF THIS COUNTRY
GIVE YOU THAT RIGHT.
[HELICOPTER].
REPORTER: THEY'VE TAKEN
THE LAW INTO THEIR OWN HANDS.
POSITIONED THEMSELVES
ON THE ROOF.
THEY ARE AL-ALSO
ARMED WITH CLUBS.
THE KOREANS HERE HAVE
PREPARED TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AGAINST ANYTHING
THAT MAY COME THEIR WAY.
MAN: THE POLICE
DIDN'T COME HERE.
WE NEED, UH, ADDITIONAL
GUARD IN HERE.
WE HAVE NO POLICE
SUPPORT WHATSOEVER.
PEOPLE ARE DRIVING BY
SHOOTING AT US AND WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
REPORTER: WELL HE'S
DRESSED FOR WAR GAMES.
REPORTER 2: THAT'S RIGHT.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT A GAME
TO THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
THE ROOF AND ARE CARRYING
RIFLES AND LOTS OF
BOXES OF AMMUNITION.
REPORTER: THAT'S FRIGHTENING.
REPORTER 3: IT CERTAINLY
IS A FRIGHTENING PICTURE.
MAN: THEY'RE SHOOTING AT US.
SO FAR WE'VE BEEN SHOOTING
UP BUT WHEN IT COMES THE
WORST WE'RE NOT GONNA SIT
AROUND SHOOTING UP SIDE.
WE'RE GONNA SHOOT AT THEM.
LINDA MOORE: ARE WE LIVE?
MAN: GO, LINDA.
YEAH, WE'RE LIVE.
LINDA MOORE: THIS
IS LINDA MOORE LIVE.
SOME OF THE KOREAN SHOP
OWNERS HERE PULLED,
PULLED OUT OF THEIR
STORES AND THEY STARTED
PULLING OUT WEAPONS.
THERE'S SOME CARS THAT
HAVE SOME GUNS IN THEM...
[GUNSHOTS].
REPORTER: WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A GUNFIGHT.
[GUNSHOTS].
[GUNSHOTS]
LINDA MOORE: SEEMS
LIKES SOMEONE'S BEEN SHOT.
WHERE?
SOMEONE'S BEEN
SHOT IN THE CAR?
I THINK, I THINK WE
SHOULD GET OUT OF HERE.
SEAN, DROP THE SIGNAL.
WE GOT TO GET OUT OF HERE.
HELICOPTER PILOT: THIS
IS HELICOPTER TO DESK.
HELICOPTER TO DESK.
CAN YOU READ ME?
DESK: HELICOPTER REPORT.
HELICOPTER PILOT: I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'VE GOT US, UH,
YOU DON'T HAVE US LIVE,
BUT IF YOU CAN SEE OUR
PICTURE WE'RE OVER THREE
FIRES IN HOLLYWOOD.
YOU SHOULD TAKE US
AS SOON AS YOU CAN.
HELICOPTER REPORTER: THAT
FIRE WAS ONE OF THREE FIRES
THAT HAD RECENTLY BROKEN
OUT IN THE HOLLYWOOD AREA.
THE OTHER WAS
JUST EAST OF THAT.
AND FRANKLY, UH, UP IN THE
AIR HERE WE CAN SEE FIRES, UH,
EASILY, UH, BEYOND THE
WATTS AND COMPTON AREA.
CLEARLY THE FIRES
ARE SPREADING.
MAN: I MEAN THE WHOLE
CITY IS UP IN FLAMES.
BUT NOW IT'S COMING
REALLY CLOSE.
REPORTER: WE ARE GETTING
REPORTS OF LOOTING FROM ALL
OVER LOS ANGELES AND
ALSO SURROUNDING AREAS.
IT'S NOT CONFINED
TO SOUTH CENTRAL,
NOT CONFINED TO THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
IT'S, UH, ALL OVER.
[INAUDIBLE RIOT BANTER].
REPORTER: VERNON CONVALESCENT
HOSPITAL, A FIRE OVER THERE,
SOMEBODY SET A FIRE IN
THE CONVALESCENT HOSPITAL.
IT WAS THE FIRE DEPARTMENT,
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT,
AND EVERYBODY ELSE THAT'S
TRYING TO HELP SCATTERED
ALL OVER THE CITY.
SO THE FIRES ARE
BURNING OUT OF CONTROL.
[ALARMS SOUNDING].
MAN: HEY, HAVE WE
GOT PEOPLE IN HERE?
HEY, HEY, GET UP
THIS DOOR, BUDDY.
[SIRENS].
[ALARMS SOUNDING].
WOMAN: DON'T YOU
DARE SET A FIRE.
YOU'LL BURN UP.
MAN: MOVE, OUT.
WOMAN: GET OUT!
MAN: NO, MOVE.
WOMAN: THIS IS
AMERICA, GET OUT.
MAN: YES, I KNOW,
YOU WANT TO GET VIOLENT?
WOMAN: NO, I
DON'T WANT A FIRE.
MAN 2: (BLEEP) THE CHINESE,
(BLEEP) THE CHINESE.
WOMAN: I'M NOT CHINESE.
MAN 2: GET OUT OF HERE,
GET OUT THE COUNTRY.
WOMAN: KEEP YOUR MOUTH SHUT!
MAN 3: HOW ARE YOU GONNA TELL
HIM TO KEEP HIS MOUTH SHUT?
WOMAN: THIS IS AMERICA.
MAN 3: NOW IF IT'S AMERICA
HOW ARE YOU GONNA TELL HIM
TO KEEP HIS MOUTH SHUT?
WOMAN: THIS IS AMERICA,
GET OUT, GET OUT!
MAN 3: GET OUT.
WOMAN: THIS IS AMERICA,
THIS IS AMERICA.
[SIRENS].
REPORTER: 21 PEOPLE
CONFIRMED DEAD AT THIS TIME.
AT LEAST 572 INJURED,
INCLUDING TWO FIREFIGHTERS.
REPORTER 2: THIS
NUMBER IS STAGGERING.
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
HOW TO TELL YOU THIS,
BUT 916 STRUCTURE
FIRES ARE BURNING IN THE
LOS ANGELES AREA, 916.
MAN: WHAT A MESS.
WOMAN: IT LOOKS
LIKE A WAR ZONE.
MAN: IT IS A WAR ZONE.
WOMAN: IT IS A WAR ZONE.
MAN: THERE'S PEOPLE DOWN
THERE WITH AUTOMATIC WEAPONS.
MAN 2: DOWNTOWN, KOREATOWN,
MID-WILSHIRE, HOLLYWOOD,
BEVERLY HILLS, CULVER
CITY ON THE RIGHT.
MAN: PEOPLE ARE GOING
CRAZY DOWN THERE.
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE
FEELING SO OPPRESSED.
AND THEN THEY'RE GONNA GO
AND BURN EVERYTHING DOWN AND
THEY'RE GONNA BE
MORE OPPRESSED.
MAN 2: WELL, THERE'S
SHIT GOING ON WITH PEOPLE
OTHER THAN, YOU KNOW,
A, A BLACK THING.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
MAN: UH-HUH.
MAN 2: YEAH, I MEAN YOU
GOT SOME PEOPLE THAT WORK
60 TO 80 HOURS.
A (BLEEP) WEEK AND STILL HAVE
BILL COLLECTORS CALLING AND
THEY SEE THEIR BOSSES
PEEL OUT IN THESE MERCS AND
THESE ROLLS' EVERY DAY AND
STROKE THEM ON THE BACK AND
TELL THEM IT'S GONNA BE ALRIGHT.
YOU KNOW, HOW LONG
CAN THAT LAST?
LAWRENCE: IT'S NOT RIGHT.
I WORKED TOO HARD FOR THIS.
MAN: PEOPLE DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND NOTHING.
COME ON.
LAWRENCE: THAT'S NOT
RIGHT, THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
MAN: COME ON, BROTHER.
LAWRENCE: THAT'S NOT
RIGHT, WHAT Y'ALL DOING.
WOMAN: LAWRENCE,
STOP IT, STOP IT.
LAWRENCE: I CAME
FROM THE GHETTO TOO.
SAME AS ALL OF YOU DID.
MAN: Y'ALL NEED TO LISTEN TO.
LAWRENCE: BUT YOU
DON'T, YOU DON'T,
YOU DON'T MESS UP MY VISION.
MAN: YOU WANT TO
SAY SOMETHING?
LAWRENCE: AND YOU
CALL THIS BLACK POWER?
HUH, YOU BETTER
THAN THE WHITE MAN?
WHY DESTROY MY BUSINESS?
WHY DESTROY MY STORE?
WHY STEAL MY COMPUTER?
I'M TRYING TO MAKE IT.
CAN'T YOU UNDERSTAND THAT?
CAN'T Y'ALL SEE IT?
I'M TRYING TO MAKE IT.
♪ ♪
OFFICER: GET IN LINE, GUYS.
KEEP THE ORDER.
LET'S GET IN LINE
AND STAND FAST.
OFFICER 2: IT WAS WORSE
THAN BEING IN VIETNAM.
AT LEAST IN VIETNAM
I COULD SHOOT BACK.
HERE WE COULDN'T DO
ANYTHING EXCEPT THERE'S PEOPLE
THROWING THINGS AT US.
ALL WE COULD DO WAS
STAND THERE AND TAKE IT.
WOMAN: ONLY WATCHING,
ONLY WATCHING, ONLY WATCHING.
OFFICER: WHAT WOULD
YOU SUGGEST WE DO?
WOMAN: AT LEAST
SOMETHING, WHY?
OFFICER: WHAT WOULD
YOU SUGGEST WE DO?
WOMAN: EVERYBODY SEE,
EVERYBODY WATCHING.
ONLY WATCHING, ONLY WATCHING.
THIS IS TOUGH, THIS IS NOT
FAIR, THIS IS NOT FAIR,
THIS IS NOT FAIR,
THIS IS NOT FAIR.
IT'S NOT FAIR, THIS IS
NOT FAIR, THIS IS NOT FAIR,
THIS IS NOT FAIR.
MAN: THAT'S NOT
GONNA HELP, SHUT UP.
WOMAN: THIS IS NOT FAIR, THIS
IS NOT FAIR, THIS IS NOT FAIR,
THIS IS NOT FAIR,
THIS IS NOT FAIR.
OFFICER: TAKE IT
DOWN THE STREET.
TAKE IT DOWN THE
STREET, MA'AM.
♪ ♪
REPORTER: THE CALIFORNIA
ARMY NATIONAL GUARD HAS BEEN
DEPLOYED TO ASSIST THE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT AND
LOS ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
IN A MUTUAL AID OPERATION TO
RESTORE LAW AND ORDER AND
TO PROTECT LIFE AND PROPERTY
IN THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
DAN: WERE YOU FRUSTRATED
TODAY BY THE APPARENT
RELUCTANCE OF THE
L.A. OFFICIALS TO USE THE
GUARD ON THE STREETS?
PETE WILSON: DAN, I DON'T
THINK THERE WAS RELUCTANCE.
I THINK THAT THERE, UH, WAS
SOME DELAY FOR LOGISTICAL
REASONS, REASONS THAT HAD TO
DO WITH EQUIPPING THE GUARD.
REPORTER: CLARIFY WHAT
THE LOGISTICAL PROBLEMS IN
EQUIPPING THE GUARD WERE?
PETE WILSON: THE CHIEF
PROBLEM HAS BEEN WITH RESPECT
TO, UH, AMMUNITION.
REPORTER: WAIT, WHAT?
CAN YOU FINISH THAT?
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM
WITH AMMUNITION?
PETE WILSON: UH,
THE TROOPS CAME BUT THE
AMMUNITION DIDN'T.
THEY CAME WITH
SOME AMMUNITION,
NOT THE FULL COMPLEMENT
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE.
THE PROBLEM WAS THAT
IT WAS SLOW IN COMING
FROM CAMP ROBERTS.
NATIONAL GUARD: GONNA
START OUT FROM WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA HEAD
TO, UH, 81'S POSITION,
HEAD TO KILO'S POSITION AND
WEAPON'S COMPANY POSITION.
THEN WE'RE GONNA
COME UP LIKE THAT.
NATIONAL GUARD 2: AND OVER?
NATIONAL GUARD:
YES SIR, SADDLE UP!
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
I DIDN'T EXPECT TO,
UH, BE ON U.S. SOIL DOING
THIS JOB EVER, EVER.
NATIONAL GUARD 2: TELL
EVERYONE DOWN THERE GET IN
THE CORNER OR SOMETHING.
NATIONAL GUARD 3:
ARE WE LOCK AND LOAD?
NATIONAL GUARD 2: LOCK AND
LOAD, ROUND IN THE CHAMBER.
NATIONAL GUARD 4: I NEVER
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE DONE,
NOT IN OUR OWN COUNTRY.
IT'S AMAZING.
NATIONAL GUARD 5:
YOU'VE GOT TO KNOW WHO,
WHO YOU'RE LOOKING AT AND,
UH, WHO YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT,
WHEREAS IN THE GULF
IT WAS A LOT EASIER.
YOU KNEW.
NATIONAL GUARD: HEY,
TAKE A CORNER, JUST STAY DOWN.
YOU SEE IT, IF YOU
TAKE ROUNDS TAKE IT UP.
GO HOME.
NATIONAL GUARD 2:
GET BACK HOME, GO.
LOUDSPEAKER: GET
OFF THE STREETS.
LEAVE THE AREA.
REPORTER:
"GET OFF THE STREETS.
LEAVE THE AREA."
THESE ARE THE POLICE,
LAPD, GOING UP AND DOWN PICO
TELLING RESIDENTS THE
CURFEW IS IN EFFECT NOW.
GET OFF THE STREETS.
LOUDSPEAKER: GET OFF
THE STREETS OR YOU'LL BE
SUBJECT TO ARREST.
LEAVE THE AREA.
[HELICOPTER].
[TONE].
EMERGENCY BROADCAST:
THIS IS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISPATCH REPORTS THAT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
IS NOW IN FULL MOBILIZATION.
[INAUDIBLE]
DUE TO THE
ESCALATION OF THE SITUATION
AND THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT ARE OCCURRING,
THE CURFEW HAS BEEN
EXTENDED TO INCLUDE THE ENTIRE
LOS ANGELES CITY LIMITS.
[TONE].
MAN: RAM 3,
THIS IS RAM 1, OVER.
RAM 3, THIS IS RAM 1, OVER.
RAM 3: RAM 3 HERE.
MAN: YEAH.
THEY GONNA TURN ON THE
SPRINKLERS OUT HERE, OKAY?
SO TO KEEP IT WET DOWN.
SO BE CAREFUL SO YOU GUYS
DON'T GET WET, UH, ALL RIGHT?
MAN 2: ALRIGHT.
MAN 3: WHAT IS THAT GONNA
DO FOR WATER PRESSURE IF THEY
NEED IT OVER HERE ON
THESE, UH, HOUSES?
MAN: WE'LL TURN IT OFF
BUT I, I DON'T THINK IT'S
GONNA MAKE THAT
BIG A DIFFERENCE.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO
IS AVOID THE SPARKS.
WOMAN: HOW'D IT GET
LIKE THAT THOUGH?
THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING.
BOY: IT'S A BIG FIRE.
GIRL: LOOK AT IT.
♪ ♪
[INAUDIBLE CHATTER]
MAN: HOW YOU DOING?
MAN 2: YOU GOT ONE?
YOU CAN HAVE ANOTHER ONE.
WOMAN: I KNOW PEOPLE GOT
INJURED BECAUSE OF THE LOOTING
AND THERE WERE POLICE ACROSS
THE STREET WATCHING IT.
THERE WAS NOTHING
THEY COULD DO.
IT WAS ALREADY OUT OF HAND.
THERE WERE TOO MANY
PEOPLE JUST GOING CRAZY,
STEPPING ALL OVER EACH OTHER.
MAN 3: I KNOW ONE THING,
HUNGRY AS I AM NOW (CHUCKLES),
IT STILL AIN'T WORTH IT.
WOMAN: I THINK THAT'S HOW
IT'S GONNA END IS PEOPLE ARE
GONNA GET HUNGRY THEN WE'RE
GONNA LOOK AROUND AND SAY:
"WHERE DO WE GO NOW?
WHERE ARE WE GONNA GO?"
MAN 3: I GUESS THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HERE, HUH?
WOMAN 2: YEAH, THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HERE.
REPORTER: THE WORLD WATCHING
US THOUGH, WE KNOW THAT.
AND THE NEWSPAPERS
FROM OTHER BIG CITIES ARE
REPORTING THEIR REACTION.
THE BRITISH MAIL
HAD A RATHER SCATHING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT.
THE SAID THAT: "RACISM IN
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
IS AS AMERICAN AS APPLE PIE."
REPORTER: LOS ANGELES
MAYOR TOM BRADLEY AND
POLICE OFFICIALS SAID TODAY
THAT THEY'RE REGAINING CONTROL
OVER THE CITY.
REPORTER 2: POLICE CHIEF
DARYL GATES ADMITTED THAT
THE POLICE FORCE GOT A SLOW
START WEDNESDAY AFTERNOON
WHEN THE VIOLENCE BEGAN.
AND GATES AND FIRE CHIEF
DONALD MANNING CONCEDED THAT
THE CITY'S FORCES
WERE OVERWHELMED.
FIREFIGHTERS DONNED
BULLETPROOF VESTS AS THEY
FOUGHT THE SCORES OF NEW FIRES
THAT WERE SET LAST NIGHT.
THERE WERE STILL
ABOUT 40 FIRES BURNING
EARLY THIS MORNING.
REPORTER 3: AT LEAST
35 PEOPLE ARE NOW SAID TO
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES.
MORE THAN 1300 PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN INJURED AND
3,000 ARRESTED.
THE CITY REMAINS UNDER A
DUSK TO DAWN CURFEW WITH MANY
STORES AND MALLS CLOSED.
MAN: OKAY, THE S.S.I.
CHECKS ARE READY, AND
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN IS,
THEY'RE PROBABLY GONNA
LET SOME OF THE PEOPLE
WITH S.S.I., UH,
CHECKS GETTING THEM FIRST.
SO WE NEED SOME
COOPERATION HERE.
[INAUDIBLE CROWD NOISE].
MAXINE WATERS:
CAN YOU HEAR ME?
CROWD: YES.
MAXINE WATERS: WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
GETS THEIR MAIL TODAY, OKAY?
[CROWD APPLAUSES, CHEERS].
I WANT YOU TO COOPERATE WITH
ME SO WE CAN DO THIS SMOOTHLY.
IF WE START A BIG MESS
RIGHT OUTSIDE HERE,
THEN THEY'RE GONNA CLOSE
THESE DOORS AND THE POLICE
ARE GONNA BE ALL OVER US.
SO WILL YOU WORK WITH ME?
CROWD: YES!
MAXINE WATERS: WILL
YOU BE PATIENT?
CROWD: YES!
MAXINE WATERS: DON'T START ANY
RIOT AT THE POST OFFICE, OKAY?
CROWD: YEAH.
MAXINE WATERS: PLEASE,
WILL YOU WORK WITH ME?
CROWD: YEAH.
MAXINE WATERS: ALRIGHT.
[CROWD APPLAUDS].
♪ ♪
[TONE].
ROSS BECKER: GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE.
I'M ROSS BECKER HERE IN
THE CHANNEL 13 NEWSROOM.
WE ARE INTERRUPTING
PROGRAMMING THIS AFTERNOON.
MOMENTARILY WE EXPECT TO HEAR
A STATEMENT FROM SOMEONE WHOSE
NAME, UH, WILL BE INDELIBLY
CONNECTED TO ALL OF THE
VIOLENCE WE HAVE SEEN
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF DAYS
IN LOS ANGELES AND
THAT IS RODNEY KING.
REPORTER: AND
WE'RE STANDING BY.
THERE'S BEEN GREAT
ANTICIPATION, UH, CERTAINLY,
UH, MR. KING, UH, HAS NOT
MADE, UH, PUBLIC STATEMENTS.
UH, HE HAS BEEN,
UH, REALLY THE, UH,
THE INVISIBLE MAN IN ALL THIS.
AND, UH, I, I DETECT SOME
MOVEMENT THROUGH THE CROWD.
YEAH, I SEE.
HERE HE COMES.
CROWD: DOWN!
DOWN, DOWN, DOWN,
HEY, DOWN, PLEASE.
♪ ♪
STEVEN LERMAN: UH,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING.
RODNEY KING HAS THIS TO SAY TO
ALL THE PEOPLE OF LOS ANGELES
AND ALL THE PEOPLE OF THE
CITIES OF THE UNITED STATES,
SO CAUGHT UP IN THIS
HORROR AND HATE.
THE KILLING, THE
BURNING, THE LOOTING,
THE CHAOS MUST STOP NOW.
THE TIME FOR
HEALING IS UPON US.
RODNEY KING HAS PREPARED
A VERY BRIEF STATEMENT.
MR. RODNEY, TALK SOFTLY.
RODNEY KING: UM, PEOPLE, UM,
I JUST, I JUST WANT TO SAY,
YOU KNOW, CAN WE,
CAN WE ALL GET ALONG?
CAN WE, CAN WE GET ALONG?
UM, CAN WE
STOP MAKING IT,
MAKING IT HORRIBLE FOR, FOR
THE, FOR THE OLDER PEOPLE
AND THE, AND THE,
AND THE, AND THE KIDS?
AND I MEAN WE'VE GOT ENOUGH
SMOG HERE IN LOS ANGELES,
UM, LET ALONE TO, UH,
DEAL WITH THE, UM,
SETTING THESE FIRES
AND, AND THINGS.
IT'S, IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT.
IT'S NOT RIGHT AND, UM,
IT'S N, IT'S NOT GONNA,
IT'S NOT GONNA
CHANGE ANYTHING.
WE'VE GOT TO,
WE'VE GOT TO QUIT.
YOU KNOW, UH, AFTER ALL, I
MEAN, I COULD UNDERSTAND THE,
THE, THE FIRST UPSET FOR THE
FIRST TWO HOURS AFTER THE
VERDICT BUT, UH, TO GO
ON, TO KEEP GOING ON LIKE,
LIKE THIS AND TO SEE THE
SECURITY GUARD SHOT ON THE,
ON THE GROUND, IT,
UM, IT'S, IT'S, UH,
IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT.
IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT
BECAUSE TH, THOSE PEOPLE ARE,
WILL NEVER GO HOME TO,
TO THEIR FAMILIES AGAIN.
AND, UH, I MEAN, PLEASE,
WE CAN, WE CAN GET ALONG HERE.
WE, WE ALL CAN GET ALONG.
WE JUST GOT TO, JUST
GOT TO, YOU KNOW,
I MEAN WE'RE ALL STUCK
HERE FOR A WHILE.
LET'S, YOU KNOW, LET'S,
LET'S, LET'S TRY TO WORK IT OUT.
LET'S TRY TO BE THE,
YOU KNOW, LET'S TRY AND
WORK IT OUT.
STEVEN LERMAN: THANK YOU.
REPORTER: STEVE,
CAN YOU ASK RODNEY?
STEVEN LERMAN: NO, NO
QUESTIONS, NO QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MAN: STEVE, STEVE AND
I WILL BE AVAILABLE IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
STEVEN LERMAN: GO AHEAD, OKAY.
♪ ♪
MAN: TEN SECONDS.
PRESIDENT BUSH:
TONIGHT, TONIGHT.
TONIGHT, TONIGHT, [HUMS].
TONIGHT I WANT TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT VIOLENCE IN
OUR CITIES AND JUSTICE
FOR OUR CITIZENS.
WHAT WE SAW LAST NIGHT AND
THE NIGHT BEFORE IN LOS ANGELES
IS NOT ABOUT CIVIL RIGHTS.
IT'S NOT A MESSAGE OF PROTEST.
IT'S BEEN THE BRUTALITY
OF A MOB, PURE AND SIMPLE.
AND LET ME ASSURE YOU,
I WILL USE WHATEVER FORCE IS
NECESSARY TO RESTORE ORDER.
WITHIN ONE HOUR
OF THE VERDICT,
I DIRECTED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO MOVE INTO HIGH
GEAR ON ITS OWN
INDEPENDENT CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE CASE.
YOU MUST UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE PROVIDES FOR
THE PEACEFUL, ORDERLY MEANS
OF ADDRESSING THIS FRUSTRATION.
WE MUST RESPECT
THE PROCESS OF LAW,
WHETHER OR NOT WE
AGREE WITH THE OUTCOME.
IN A CIVILIZED SOCIETY
THERE CAN BE NO EXCUSE,
NO EXCUSE FOR THE
MURDER, ARSON,
THEFT AND VANDALISM
THAT HAVE TERRORIZED THE
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
OF LOS ANGELES.
NONE OF THIS IS WHAT WE
WISH TO THINK OF AS AMERICAN.
IT'S AS IF WE WERE LOOKING
IN A MIRROR THAT DISTORTED
OUR BETTER SELVES AND
TURNED US UGLY.
WE CANNOT LET THAT HAPPEN.
WE CANNOT DO THAT
TO OURSELVES.
IF WE ARE TO REMAIN THE
MOST VIBRANT AND HOPEFUL
NATION ON EARTH,
WE MUST ALLOW OUR DIVERSITY
TO BRING US TOGETHER,
NOT DRIVE US APART.
THE VIOLENCE WILL END,
JUSTICE WILL BE SERVED.
HOPE WILL RETURN.
THANK YOU AND MAY GOD BLESS
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
REPORTER: PRESIDENT GEORGE
BUSH AND HIS ADDRESS TO THE
NATION FROM THE OVAL OFFICE.
TIME FOR YOUR REACTIONS ONCE
AGAIN FROM AROUND THE COUNTRY.
FT. WASHINGTON, MARYLAND.
YOU'RE ON THE AIR.
CALLER: FIRST OF ALL,
MR. BUSH SPOKE OF THE LAST
48 HOURS AS IF IT'S THE
FIRST TIME HE'S NOTICED
THAT AMERICA HAS A PROBLEM.
UH, IT'S ALWAYS HAD A
PROBLEM FROM ITS INCEPTION
FROM 1776 WHEN THEY SAID,
UH, ALL MEN WERE CREATED
EQUAL AND WE HAD SLAVERY.
CALLER 2: IT WAS STRIKING TO
ME THAT THERE WAS NO DIRECT
STATEMENT TO THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN POPULATION AND THERE
WAS COMPLETELY MISSING ANY
SENSE OF A REALITY ABOUT HOW A
NATIONAL LEADER MIGHT MOVE
PEOPLE TOWARDS RECONCILIATION.
CALLER 3: PEOPLE HAVE TO SEE
THAT THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO
MAKE THEIR VOICES HEARD.
IF THEY ALLOW, WHEN
THEY HEAR A POLITICIAN,
TO TRY TO EXPLAIN THIS AWAY
AS BEING THUGS AND MURDERERS,
THINGS WILL NOT CHANGE.
THIS HAS GOT TO BE
A PEOPLE MOVEMENT.
UH, PEOPLE CAN
MOVE POLITICIANS.
THE COMMUNITY LEADS.
THEY DON'T FOLLOW.
POLITICIANS FOLLOW.
THEY DON'T LEAD.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE TO REMEMBER.
[HORN HONKING].
[CHANTING "STOP THE VIOLENCE"]
MAN: WE ARE GOING TO
SHOW THEM THAT HERE,
THE LATINO REALLY WANTS
TO SUPPORT THIS CITY.
WE NEED THEM TO BRING
JUST BROOMS AND GLOVES,
AND THE CHILDREN, AND THEIR
ENTIRE FAMILY WILL BEGIN TO
CLEAN THE WHOLE CITY.
CROWD: STOP THE VIOLENCE,
STOP THE VIOLENCE.
WOMAN: YOU KNOW, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SEE THE FULL
SCOPE; THE BURNING, THE
LOOTING, AND THE CLEANING UP.
A PERSONAL OPINION IS
JUST THAT, YOU KNOW,
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO WORK
TOGETHER AND IF THIS CAN JUST
CONTINUE IT'D BE WONDERFUL.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
I DON'T THINK IT WILL.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, A
FEW PEOPLE SAY OKAY,
I PUT IN MY TIME.
I HELPED CLEAN.
AND THEY'RE NOT
GONNA DO ANYTHING.
YOU KNOW, PROVE ME WRONG.
YOU KNOW, OH GOD,
PROVE ME WRONG.
YOU KNOW?
MAN: ALRIGHT, WE HAD ENOUGH,
THAT'S RIGHT, FOR PEACE.
[HORN HONKING].
WOMAN: THAT'S RIGHT.
HONK FOR PEACE,
HONK FOR PEACE.
REPORTER: I WAS DRIVING
DOWN WESTERN BELOW WILSHIRE AND
I LOOKED TO THE LEFT
AND SAW A SEA OF PEOPLE.
THESE ARE KOREAN-AMERICANS
WHO GATHERED TODAY TO
CALL FOR PEACE.
MAN: THIS IS OUR CITY AND
MUST NOT DESTROY OUR OWN HOMES.
TO STAND UNITED TO
STOP ANY FURTHER SENSELESS
VIOLENCE AND DESTRUCTION.
REPORTER: MOST OF THEM ARE
WEARING WHITE HEADBANDS.
THEY SAY THAT IS
A SYMBOL OF PEACE.
THE ONE SIGN THOUGH THAT
STOOD OUT IN MY MIND THE MOST
WAS A SIGN THAT SAID,
"WE KNOW IT WAS INJUSTICE.
WE KNOW IT WAS INJUSTICE."
MAN: WE STAND TOGETHER
WITH ALL THOSE WHO WANT
JUSTICE IN THE KING CASE.
WE MUST STOP POLICE
ABUSE WHEREVER IT OCCURS.
CROWD: WHAT DO YOU WANT?
PEACE.
WHEN DO WE WANT IT?
NOW.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
PEACE.
WHEN DO YOU WANT IT?
NOW.
WHAT DO YOU WANT?
[INAUDIBLE CHANTING]
WOMAN: THROUGHOUT HISTORY,
THE ONLY POWER I BELIEVE THAT
THE POWER POOR PEOPLE HAVE AND
POWERLESS PEOPLE HAVE IN THIS
COUNTRY COMES FROM OUR UNRULY
BEHAVIOR, OUR, OUR, OUR RE,
OUR RESISTANCE TO AN
ORDER THAT WOULD PLACE US
AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE TOTEM POLE.
CROWD CHANTING: WE WANT
JUSTICE, WE WANT PEACE.
WE WANT JUSTICE,
WE WANT PEACE.
♪ ♪
REPORTER: THIS
IS WHERE IT BEGAN.
THIS IS WHERE THE
FUSE WAS LIGHTED.
IT BEGAN WITH THE ARREST
BY WHITE OFFICERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OF TWO YOUNG NEGROS,
ONE ON A CHARGE
OF DRUNK DRIVING.
THERE WAS AN ARGUMENT.
THERE WAS A SCUFFLE.
THE STORY OF POLICE
BRUTALITY QUICKLY SPREAD
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY.
UP THE STREET A BLOCK
OR SO IN THAT DIRECTION,
A CHURCH WHERE NEGRO
LEADERS PLEADED FOR PEACE
AND WERE REJECTED.
DOWN THAT WAY, THE BUSY
INTERSECTION WHERE CARS WERE
OVERTURNED AND BURNED,
WHERE OTHER CARS WERE STONED,
WHERE A TELEVISION TECHNICIAN
WAS PULLED FROM HIS WAGON AND
ALMOST BEATEN TO DEATH.
JOHN SHABAZ: WHAT HAS CHANGED?
THE ONLY THING THAT WE'VE DONE
WAS THAT MASSIVE FORCES WERE
BROUGHT IN TO SUPPRESS
THE ACTUAL OVERT ACTION.
RAMONA RIPSTON: THE INCIDENT
IS NOT AN ISOLATED INCIDENT.
THE DIFFERENCE THIS TIME
IS THAT WE HAVE THE PROOF.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
WOMAN: YOU'RE GUILTY,
YOU'RE GUILTY.
MAN: EVERY TIME SOMEBODY
TALK ABOUT PEACE WE GET
A FOOT IN OUR ASS.
I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT PEACE NO MORE.
[YELLING INAUDIBLY].
PRESIDENT BUSH: IN A
CIVILIZED SOCIETY THERE CAN BE
NO EXCUSE FOR THE.
LYNSON JOHNSON: MURDER,
PILLAGE, LOOTING,
AND ARSON HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH CIVIL RIGHTS.
MAN 2: "GET OUT OF
THE CAR, NIGGER.
ASSUME THE POSITION, NIGGER.
SIT ON THE CURB, NIGGER.
LIE FACE DOWN ON
THE GROUND, NIGGER."
MAN 3: WHY SHOULD
NOT WE GET RESTLESS?
MAN 4: I DON'T THINK
IT'D EVER STOP, REALLY.
I MEAN, IT MAY NOT BE LIKE
THIS, BUT IT'LL NEVER STOP.
WOMAN 2: THIS IS NOT
FAIR, THIS IS NOT FAIR,
THIS IS NOT FAIR,
THIS IS NOT FAIR.
MAN 5: THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HELP.
WOMAN 2: THIS IS NOT
FAIR, THIS IS NOT FAIR,
THIS IS NOT FAIR,
THIS IS NOT FAIR.
BILL STOUT: A CRISIS
IN OUR COUNTRY SAYS
THE MCCONE COMMISSION.
SO SERIOUS AND EXPLOSIVE IS
THE SITUATION THAT UNLESS IT
IS CHECKED, THE AUGUST RIOTS
MAY BE ONLY A CURTAIN RAISER
TO WHAT COULD BLOW UP
ONE DAY IN THE FUTURE.
WHAT SHALL IT AVAIL OUR
NATION IF WE CAN PLACE A MAN
ON THE MOON BUT CANNOT CURE
THE SICKNESS IN OUR CITIES?
THIS IS BILL STOUT FOR
CBS REPORTS IN LOS ANGELES.
GOOD NIGHT.
♪ [MUSIC PLAYS
THROUGH CREDITS] ♪